Uh,
could you tell me what you had for breakfast please?
Oh my head,
my usual coffee and protein bar wall staring out the window and wishing I'd eat
more calories
to what I can flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living this year.
This episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch
of my startups already use Vimeo pro including wealth front who uses it to
explain how wealth front works task grab,
it uses it to tell their company story and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers,
airbnb,
Etsy,
et cetera.
Why do they use it?
Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost.
Features include gorgeous high quality playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and they fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro,
et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated bandwidth calculations or hidden fees and
you can try it risk free for 30 days,
so check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business that's vim,
e o.com forward slash business and use Promo Code Tim to get 25% off.
That's a special discount just for you guys.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business Promo Code Tim,
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website and APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers,
as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Hello my hetero genius homosapiens homicidal Tom Cats.
That doesn't make any sense.
I was going to say homicidal Homo Sapiens,
but heterogeneous.
Why don't we say heterogeneous like Raj Innocence?
I don't know.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to the Tim Ferriss.
My job every episode is to deconstruct a world class performer and to show you
how they do what they do.
What are the favorite books,
the routines,
the habits?
How did they achieve the success they've achieved?
Whether they are chess prodigies like Josh Waitzkin or actors like Arnold
Schwarzenegger,
director like Jon Favreau,
Comedians,
athletes,
hedge fund managers.
We've got everybody startup impresarios like Peter Teal.
And so on this time we have by request,
Scott Adams.
Scott Adams is a very famous cartoonist.
He's the creator of the Dilbert Comic Strip and the author of several different
books that are nonfiction.
And he and I have a very wide ranging conversation we've met before and we cover
things such as his use of affirmations,
written affirmations for the Stock Market for success with women for his career.
As a cartoonist,
we talk about hypnosis,
why he became interested in hypnosis,
common misconceptions about hypnosis and uh,
how he used different techniques or aspects of what he learned to make Delbert
popular.
Even the name itself,
he goes into,
we talk about a current fascination of his,
which I say,
which,
or who is Donald Trump and,
uh,
the negotiator in chief that he is a campaigning to become.
And a why the political press misses a lot of the genius that perhaps the
business press should catch a,
we talk about goals versus systems.
So how he has approached his life with systems in many cases instead of goals.
And he and I,
oddly or perhaps not so coincidentally,
share a lot in common there.
We talk about his first ever Dilbert check the six dimensions of humor.
So how can you engineer humor in say,
a comic strip or elsewhere?
And we talk about the most underrated comic book strips and comics and his
opinion how he got into the best shape of his life at 58 and much,
much more.
It's a really fun conversation.
He is one hell of a character,
a very hilarious guy as you would hope.
And uh,
the banter is a,
I found a really good time.
So I hope that comes across via audio.
And without further ado,
please enjoy Scott Adams and say hi to him.
It is at Scott.
Adam says on Twitter.
So give a give a hello give a thank you.
Give him some feedback and uh,
there you have it there without further ado is a little premature.
But here we go.
Without further ado,
Scott Adams,
please enjoy
Scott,
my good man.
Welcome to the show.
Hey,
thanks for having me.
I am so excited to have you on because many of the guests who've been on this
podcast are fans of yours.
I'm a fan of your work and have you personally.
And there there are few things I'd like to thank you for.
The first is helping me to learn different languages because I bought the
Dilbert principle in many different languages,
Chinese,
Spanish,
German,
English as a way to learn conversational languages,
number one.
And then number two is for your tennis lesson,
which was the first proper tennis lesson I've ever had.
So right off the bat I wanted to thank you for being very good at helping me to
make progress in both of those areas.
Oh,
there's so much I can teach you,
Tim.
We're just,
we're just getting started.
Well,
you,
you know,
the,
the language is in tennis.
Go along the way.
I feel like,
you know,
have,
have tennis racket and a few words,
we'll travel the way I gotta tell you,
the first time I saw one of my books translated into Portuguese,
I think I had this strange sensation that I could speak the language because I
knew what the word said.
I was the coolest thing.
Well that is,
that is actually really related because I,
what I'll do is with these languages,
if I learned for instance,
uh,
Japanese first,
then I will use the Japanese and say a target language of Spanish to learn the
Spanish and other words.
I already know what's in the book on some level,
just like memorizing lines in a movie.
But I will use the Japanese to help me learn the Spanish so that they're linked
together.
And that way I get to review previous languages while learning new languages.
And I was so impressed with how you were able to teach me tennis,
uh,
or at least get me up and running with the basics in such a very short period of
time.
And I feel like you,
you're very methodical in many different areas and you have methods that other
people can use.
And one of the specific behaviors that I'd love to hear you perhaps elaborate on
just right off the bat is the idea of verbal or written affirmations.
So neval one of our mutual friends was on this podcast and she was mentioning
that at some point,
at least based on in on his recollection,
you had gone into your office at the time and gone into the bathroom and said to
yourself in the mirror,
I will be a successful cartoonist or something like that.
Multiple Times.
I've also heard that you write things down,
say 10,
15 times.
Could you perhaps explain a bit of how you use affirmations?
If you do,
you have accidentally given me the greatest um,
beginning anecdote to a long explanation.
Anybody ever did so.
All right.
Oh man,
true story.
Just a few days ago I was having dinner with novel and I'm just making
conversation.
You know,
we haven't seen him in awhile and just randomly,
because I knew I was coming onto your podcast and said live all,
if you've ever done the,
you know,
Tim Ferriss podcast and he gets us weird expression in his face and he says,
I just came from there was,
it was the most random thing and the two people who could have said to each
other after not seeing for a while,
but that,
that weird story.
It's a story about coincidence,
right?
Yeah.
There's no magic that happened there.
It was just a strange coincidence and it probably wasn't even a coincidence
because the fact that we both know you and you know there's something in the air
and maybe you bunch your bunch of interviews in a certain way or think about
them a certain way.
So I'm sure there's no real coincidence there.
There's just something we didn't see underlying it all.
So that's the backdrop for affirmations.
Let me say first that what I'm saying is not my belief that if you say your
affirmations,
something magical will happen and the universal will change and in some non
science way.
All right.
So I'd never had made that claim,
although often people have put that,
uh,
opinion in my mouth.
What I have said is that I've used the technique and I got a certain experience,
which I'll be happy to share.
And then I tell the story.
All right,
you can make of it what you will.
I have several explanations for why there seems to be what I would call the,
the appearance of an effect,
which by the way,
we'd be amazing in itself.
Of course,
you could give yourself a genuine feeling that you had a superpower even if it
wasn't real,
as long as it didn't interfere with your job,
nobody thought you were crazy.
It'd be a cool feeling.
So,
so even if it's not real,
in some sense of reality,
still worth having,
frankly.
So we'd have,
um,
I,
I'm going to take as long as I want it for this and you can just cut me off.
It's a fun story from beginning to end.
I live with a lot of people ask,
this is what,
uh,
this is what this format is for longform.
Please go for it.
Yeah.
So I'm in my twenties.
I was taking a course in hypnosis to learn how to become a professional,
hidden the test and get certified in my class was a woman who was also
interested in lots of things that I thought were pretty out there.
So new agey stuff.
But we became friends and one day she said,
you got to try this thing called affirmations.
I read about it in a book and I don't remember the name of the book.
And so I can't tell you here,
cause she couldn't tell me.
And she said,
it works like this.
All you do is you,
you pick a goal in your,
write it down in 15 times a day and some specific sentence form like eyes got
Adam,
this will become an astronaut for example.
And you do that every day.
And uh,
then it will seem as if the universe just start spitting up opportunities and it
will look to you like these are coincidences and whether they're or not is less
relevant than the fact that they seem to pop up.
So I of course being my rational self,
you know,
at this point I haven't even decided if hypnosis is a real thing.
Right?
Right.
You know,
I'm taking the course to find out in part.
And so I'm saying,
you know,
that seems like a terrible waste of time.
There's no science behind that,
blah,
blah.
She convinced me partly because she was a member of Mensa,
uh,
that she wasn't dumb.
Uh,
step.
That's good.
And then secondly,
it didn't cost me anything.
Right.
It was a low investment for something to make her shut up.
So I said,
hi,
I'm going to do this thing.
So I picked as my goal,
um,
that I would have an encounter with a woman who is well beyond my buying power,
shall we say.
This is pre Dilbert.
So,
you know,
post,
post Delbert you get to add a few points to your,
to your attractive,
the scale.
It's not fair,
but that's just the way it works.
So,
so let's say if,
you know,
if I could modestly say I was,
uh,
six,
hoping to be a six and a half,
let's say she was at a nine,
just so you know,
you get a sense of the monumental task.
I,
I sat in front of myself.
Secondly,
I didn't know her.
She was just somebody who worked in the company in a different department.
So I'll shorten the story just to say lucky things happened and against all
odds,
my affirmation came true.
So I thought to myself as everybody would in this situation.
Well it's not really the affirmation that it worked.
That would be crazy,
right?
Because even though it was a whole bunch of ridiculous coincidences that put us
in the same place,
you know,
at the same time,
I mean,
you wouldn't believe the number of them and I,
I won't tell them here,
cause there there's just too many.
But in the end it was almost like we were fated to meet right now I don't
believe in that,
but it just felt like that that's the experience.
So I said to myself,
well,
I guess I've misinterpreted this.
And really what happened is I'm not in six and a half,
dammit,
I must be her level,
or maybe,
maybe I'm a seven and a half and maybe she's a nine,
but she's got,
you know,
poor self image.
So she didn't know it.
So maybe that's all that happened,
right?
So I said,
well,
I'm going to have to try something else.
So I said,
all right,
I'll try it.
Affirmation of I'll get rich in the stock market.
Yeah,
that's kind of a crazy thing to ask for,
especially if you don't even have a stock brokerage account open.
And if you don't have any money to invest,
I think I was,
you know,
a poor banking,
uh,
person,
a banker.
That was.
And so I started doing that affirmation.
And after about a week,
I literally woke up in the middle of the night,
sat straight up in my bed with a thought firmly in my head that I should buy
stock.
And Chrysler at the time,
I don't remember the year,
but if,
you know,
if you went through the historical records,
it was when Chrysler was flirting with the completely going out of business who
was,
I don't know if they were officially bankrupt,
but they were,
they were,
uh,
the government had pumped them up and most observers were saying,
you know,
this is sort of the,
the company that's circling the drain.
So it didn't seem like a good idea and,
but I tried to open my Schwab account anyway and pursue it just to see,
you know,
we're still in ab testing here to see us.
This is real.
But the paperwork got mixed up and it took weeks to sort it out.
And I didn't get my account opened it.
In the meantime,
the stock starts rising.
Yeah.
I think it would up to hundred 20% in the time that I wasted trying to open my
account.
So I thought to myself,
damn,
I was kind of right.
You know,
I mean,
I picked a pretty good stock,
but you know,
my timing's off.
So I guess the affirmation thing wasn't really working.
So I didn't buy that stock.
If you,
if you go back,
you'll find out it continued to go up because it turns out Chrysler did,
it turned around.
It was one of the great business success stories of all time.
I knew nothing about that except,
you know,
the headline news.
Um,
before I,
I came up with this idea.
In other words,
there was no story.
I ran,
no analyst was ahead of it.
It just came from nowhere or so it's always seemed,
but I lost out because I didn't it,
I guess.
Right.
I didn't buy and it became kind of the story stock of the year.
So I tried it one more time.
I said,
uh,
I think I'll try to,
you know,
buy one more stock and I do the affirmations and one day I pick up the newspaper
and I just had this feeling and I opened it up and there's a,
uh,
back in the day when a company was going public,
they would sometimes put a,
uh,
a big notice in the newspaper and it was a company called ask computer ask or as
software,
I forgot.
But there were a new tech company back before tech was anything.
And I said,
Hey,
I'm gonna Invest in this company.
I just feel it put in some money.
I think it went up,
I don't know,
10% of the week,
whatever it was.
I thought,
Ooh,
I'm a genius.
I think I invested about it.
Thousand dollars might've made a hundred which was big money for a week of doing
nothing.
You know when you're,
when you're not making enough money to save money,
but make it $100 for nothing,
seemed like a big deal.
So I'm thinking,
man,
I am so smart.
I sold my stock and that fricking stock went to the moon us.
And now I've got these three,
these three data points.
Right?
And the only thing that stopped me from the to doing very well for me is that I
didn't stay with them.
So I said,
well,
it would be dumb if this thing actually has something to it to set another goal
that's relatively modest,
right?
So,
so there was another thing I did first,
let me insert that before I went back.
I also made a bet with somebody that would take the,
uh,
the g mats,
the test you take to get it into a good school for your Mba.
Um,
bees,
I taken them right after I'd finished by four year degree and I'd got,
I think the 77th percentile,
which is nowhere near enough to get into a school like Berkeley,
which,
which would make a difference in my career.
So I made a bet with somebody who's going to take a prep course.
They were going to try to,
uh,
raise their score from the 80s and something,
perhaps the,
the nineties,
uh,
in order to get into a good school again,
like Berkeley.
So I made a bet,
and I don't know why I made this bad.
It was just stupid in retrospect.
I bet that I would raise my score from 77th percentile to whatever was her new
best score.
So I would beat not only your other score,
which already beat me by over 10 points,
I think.
Or maybe,
you know,
she was in the high eighties,
I think,
but I thought that would beat her new score.
And I wasn't going to take a test preparation course.
I was just going to take some practice tests on my own at home.
So I did that.
But I,
I paired it with the affirmation and then,
uh,
I also visualized,
which is part of the process and they tell you to do very specifically what my
score would look like on the exact document I knew I would get because I had
taken this test before,
years earlier.
And so I would imagine that in that little box where the,
the cumulative score was,
I would see the,
the number 94 and so I just kept focusing on do I need for it,
because I figured that would be close enough that if I got anywhere in that
range,
um,
you know,
then I'm probably going to get into a good school if I want to.
So we take the test.
I,
my,
everyone in my practice tests,
I got about the same as the first time.
I took it somewhere in the high seventies.
Uh,
percentile.
I take the test felt exactly the same as all the practice tests.
I didn't feel like I was having a good day or anything.
Weeks passed,
the test shows up in the mail.
I go to the mailbox,
I opened the mail and they opened that letter and it's the same,
same kind of format that I'd visualized.
So I knew exactly what it looked like and I looked out into the little box where
for weeks I had been visualizing the number 94 and I looked at it and the
fucking things said 94
all right.
This was after the stock market experience.
Yeah,
I'm getting my timing mixed up.
It was sitting there were roughly in that period.
Right.
So I literally sat there in my little mold covered literally apartment in San
Francisco,
in the Haight district.
I sat in a chair and I stared forward for hours and all night long.
I would,
I would say to myself,
I don't think I just saw that.
And then I would reach over on my table and pick up the little a report and I
would look at it again and I would make sure I was scouring the document and not
reading like a date or you know,
a serial number or something.
Right.
And it was right.
And I'd put her down and then I would just repeat that process for hours.
And at the other day I said,
I think I'm going to set my sights higher.
And it wasn't long after I decided to start the affirmation,
my Scott Adams would become a famous cartoonist.
So Abby was,
there were some years that passed in between and then some other affirmations.
But that's,
that's essentially the,
the path I took.
So the odds of becoming a famous cartoonist,
uh,
I think about 2000 people submit packages do this.
The big syndicates,
the people who give you the big contract,
your big break,
um,
uh,
they might pick a half dozen of them.
Of those half dozen,
most of them will not make it after a year or two.
So it's a very rare,
in fact,
Dilbert was probably one of the,
you know,
I think the biggest breakout,
we're one of the biggest in 20 years just to look at the affirmations.
I have a number of questions about this and then I want to ask you about God's
debris also because I think this is maybe there's an interesting tie in,
but Oh,
if I could,
because I think your,
your listeners want to hear this.
I know.
Sure.
Interrupt you here,
but no,
no.
And trucked all you want.
The two other affirmations that are notable was,
um,
I said that I would become a number one bestselling author before I'd ever
written a book and I'd never taken a class in writing,
you know,
except a one,
I think a two day course in business writing.
And that was it.
And the Dilbert principle became the number one bestselling book the next time I
used it.
Because after that,
pretty much everything I wanted,
I got,
you know,
right.
Because with success,
you don't need the affirmation so much because just everything starts being
attracted to you automatically.
But there was a period,
and I know you get asked about this later,
where I lost my voice,
right?
Couldn't speak for three and a half years.
Yeah,
we'll talk about that later I think.
But,
uh,
that was the,
the next time I used affirmations and the affirmation was I,
Scott Adams will speak perfectly.
Now I realize I don't speak perfectly,
but with,
when we get to that story,
you'll see that,
uh,
there's more to it.
And if,
if we were to look at just the,
the mechanics of these affirmations,
are you sitting down in the morning and writing down 15 lines,
kind of like Bart Simpson on the chalkboard on a piece of paper.
How exactly were you doing it?
And then,
um,
how do you expect a lakes exactly.
Yeah.
I will start by saying,
well,
I'll tell you exactly how I did it,
but then I'll also tell you that I'm positive.
The exact method doesn't matter.
I think what matters is the degree of focus and the commitment you have to that
focus.
Right?
Because the last affirmation I mentioned was primarily done in my head while
driving.
But,
uh,
you know,
continuously for years.
Dot.
Three years.
Um,
so the way I did it back in those times was I used a pencil or a pen and a piece
of paper and I wrote the same sentence 15 times a day,
once a day,
I think.
I mean,
there would be nothing wrong with doing it twice a day,
except it's twice as hard.
So I don't think there's a reason that you should do it twice a day.
I don't know if 15 is magic,
I'm sure 10 would get you there.
20 might be better.
But I doubt it.
I don't think it matters.
And by the way,
these are the questions that everybody asks me all the time.
You know,
do you save the piece of paper?
No.
All right.
You don't save the paper.
The paper is irrelevant.
If you type it,
I'm positive you'll get the same result.
I don't know if this works.
I mean,
again,
I'm not telling you that affirmation.
This is a thing that actually happens as opposed to a perception that you have.
But I'm sure the perception at least would be the same if you were typing it as
opposed to writing it.
So I think all of the details don't matter.
Here's why I think it seems to work and there are several possibilities for
that.
One is something a I learned long ago and I forget who coined it,
but uh,
if you ever heard the phrase reticular activation I have.
Yeah.
So it's basically the idea that it's easy to hear your own name spoken in a
crowd.
All right,
so you,
you'll hear background noise as well.
Ah,
Tim Ferriss,
Blah Blah Blah.
And he like,
how did I hear that one thing and this whole bunch of crowd noise.
So basically your brain is incapable of,
of processing everything in its environment or even coming close.
So the best it can do is set up these little filters.
And the way it sets its filters is by what you pay attention to,
right?
It's what you spend the most energy on.
It's how you focus your memory.
That's how you set your filter.
So your filter is automatically assigned for your name because that's just,
you know,
the thing that matters most to you.
But you can use these affirmations.
Presumably this is just a hypothesis to focus your mind and your memory on a
very specific thing.
And that would allow you to notice things in your environment that might have
already been there.
It's just that your filter was set to ignore and then you just tune it with,
through this memory and repetition trick until it widens a little bit to allow,
allow some extra stuff in.
Now,
uh,
there's some science to back that Dr. Richard Weisman,
did some studies.
I look and he was trying to find out if people actually have real luck,
you know,
can they guess the future better than other people in the answer?
As you might guess,
and I'm sure the people listening to this podcast are all rationalist and
skeptics and you know that he found nothing,
right?
Nobody can guess random events better than other people.
But he did another test,
which I'll shorten here,
but the,
the idea was that people who expect it to be lucky,
that people who labeled themselves lucky and looked for luck everywhere,
we're a little bit better at finding it.
In other words,
just actually noticing it in the environment.
So if your filter is tuned to this thought,
hey,
I think there's something out there.
Lucky,
let me look for it.
Where's Waldo?
Where's there's Waldo?
All right,
you're going to find a little bit more and more often than the guy who says it
was nothing to look for.
I already know everything's going to go wrong.
I'll tell you tomorrow,
tomorrow I was going to be meeting going wrong.
Bad Day.
He,
York Ray went right.
So that guy's just not looking for anything,
right?
So now let me give you an anecdote to tie that together.
During the time I was telling myself I want it to be,
you know,
a cartoonist,
how do you do that?
Like,
you know,
where this was pre internet,
I didn't know where to search for it and I didn't know anybody.
Um,
I came home and I noticed,
all right,
I noticed something I'd never seen before.
Maybe it had always been there,
I dunno,
but I noticed a card,
a show,
a TV show about how to become a cartoonist.
And I wrote to the host of the show and ask for some advice.
He gave it to me,
short story,
uh,
even shorter,
um,
that sent me on the road to,
to know how to buy the book that I needed in and submit my materials and that
sort of thing.
Now you could say,
well,
that was just a coincidence because maybe that shall only aired once and,
uh,
I think it was on public TV.
So it actually probably heard lots of times.
But,
um,
there might've been other things I would have noticed.
It wasn't just that one thing I could have noticed.
I might've noticed other things that would have sent me on a different path,
but also toward this,
this thing I'd been focusing on right now.
The other possibility,
um,
every rational person in the audience is screaming,
you know,
at their,
uh,
their speaker right now.
You idiot.
This is selective memory.
Um,
what,
what's really happening is there are lots of times that you were focusing on
things and do a affirmations and you're just,
you just freaking forgot those tights.
A survivorship bias.
Right?
Right.
Um,
I say absolutely.
That's completely possible.
Right?
But I just told him my story and I can tell you that I don't have a memory in
all of those years of trying it when it didn't work.
I do have plenty of memories of when it hadn't worked yet.
Like I said,
the voice problem took a year's.
Um,
and yeah,
I suppose if I were doing one in particular right now,
uh,
that I could say it hadn't happened yet.
So,
so there's that.
Um,
but there's also just the fact that,
um,
it may be a self identification thing.
And what I mean by that is,
uh,
I have a view that we're mostly moist robots in the sense of,
you know,
the,
the environment that is programming us.
And,
you know,
we've got a little DNA that's like our operating system,
but basically,
you know,
you start with that and that can vary a lot.
Right?
Your DNA is a little bit,
a little bit of a,
a window of how much your,
you know,
your nature,
it can change,
but that's like a computer,
right?
And then the environment programs it within its parameters.
So you got that going on.
So you've got a person who's just getting,
you know,
programmed by the environment,
but they don't know that,
right?
They think they're making decisions and using their free will.
So it could be that all that's happening is that a person who is willing to
write down their goal 15 times a day has in their dis at their disposal without
necessarily knowing it.
A subconscious that is totally on their side.
In other words,
there's something in the subconscious that is overriding the conscious and say,
you know,
Scott,
we're going to do this thing.
You haven't figured it out yet.
All right?
But I'm doing the affirmations,
doing the affirmations.
So what I'm,
what I'm suggesting is it's not the affirmations that are making something
happen.
This thing is going to happen because my subconscious already decided that I
have these objectives,
I have these goals and I'm going to chew through a fricking wall to make these
happen,
right?
And I have some capabilities so I can,
I can chew,
you know,
I'm a good shoer.
So maybe all of this happening is that a person like me who has the subconscious
that's guiding him towards this very specific outcome is also the same person
who was willing to write it down 15 times,
right?
So in other words,
the causation is exactly backwards from how it looks,
right?
I'm already that person who's going to make this happen.
And I'm also by coincidence a person who is so intent on it,
then I'll try anything.
And one of those things just happens to be writing stuff down and 15 dogs,
right?
Well,
it's,
it's uh,
it's like looking at parents and who credit being good parents with buying books
a,
B,
and c,
and you're like,
well,
maybe it's just that the people who are predisposed to being good parents are
the same people who are likely to buy a bunch of books.
And study how maybe,
and maybe just maybe I've got three
links were raised in an identical situations that we all turned out completely
different.
Like,
do you just say that to anybody and watch them get the doe in the headlights,
headlights look like,
okay,
you're just change everything I know about life.
I will now erase that.
Yeah,
go on.
But I do think that,
you know,
you bring up a couple of really important topics and,
and I think helpful lenses through which to view behaviors.
So the first is,
uh,
this,
this potential combination of,
uh,
optimism and,
being an opportunist,
which I think perhaps the,
uh,
affirmations,
right?
So for instance,
people might say,
well,
the people who go to silicon valley or more successful because they're driven,
they go to silicon valley,
they build tech companies and so on.
Uh,
I would argue there's probably more to that story.
And one plausible explanation is people in Silicon Valley believe certain
impossibles are possible,
whereas they wouldn't be in a peer group elsewhere that would support that.
Right?
So they're encouraged to try these things that would see doomed,
seem doomed to fail in many other parts of the world.
And if you're able to achieve that,
uh,
in isolation by using these affirmations,
then you have this sort of a naive optimism that then provides you with this.
Uh,
like you said,
selective attention and optimism where you'll,
you'll,
you'll write to the host of the TV show,
right?
It's kind of like the sixth sense and noticing the red door knob or you buy a
new car and then you go out and you see the new car everywhere.
It's not that everyone went out and bought the same car to be like you.
It's that you're now noticing it.
How did you decide to write what rights,
uh,
God's debris?
What was,
what is the story behind that?
Because when I,
when I pinged my audience to ask what they would like to know from you,
um,
many people are familiar with Dilbert.
I would suspect a lot of people are probably not familiar with God's debris,
but the,
the premise and everything about the book is really fascinating.
Could you describe how that,
how that came about?
Yeah.
Um,
for the readers,
not or the listeners not familiar with the God's debris,
that's a non humor or non Dilbert book.
I wrote,
um,
2001 I think,
and it's a,
essentially a conversation between a delivery man and the smartest person in the
world,
um,
that he beats by accident.
He thinks,
and the challenge of the book was to write in the,
in the voice of someone who is allegedly the smartest person in the world.
Someone who literally knows everything.
Now,
the problem is,
since I don't know everything,
you know,
how do you figure out that out?
So that my writers solution was my version of Ockham's razor,
sort of a bastardized version in which I simply had the alleged smartest person
in the world say the things that seemed like the simplest explanations.
And it turns out when you read the simplest explanation,
even if it's not what you were already set the believe or already did believe,
it's very compelling.
Anyway,
it's just one of those ways.
Your brain is wired.
That simplicity looks compelling.
You know,
Ronald Reagan Iee,
Donald Trump.
Simplicity is always compelling.
But the larger part,
you know that the content of the book,
and this won't mean as much as the people who haven't read it,
but it will mean a whole bunch of the people who have.
You're probably wondering how the hell does anybody think of those different
ideas and have them fit together in the same book?
Uh,
that's one of the questions I get asked the most and the answer is you don't do
it intentionally write that stuff does not happen because you had a plan.
That book is the result of literally a my lifetime.
Up to that point.
It was 40 ish years.
I forget.
Um,
and all the strange thoughts I'd had and one specific moment in my shower at
which I realized,
Holy Hell,
these are all the same idea.
And they have a theme,
which I can now weave them together into one grand idea,
which if I put it in the voice of someone,
not myself,
you know,
then put it in the form of fiction.
It will give the reader the same feeling that I had when the census came to me
in the shower where I got a full body tingle.
I felt like maybe everything I knew was wrong.
Um,
not really,
but you know,
I'm talking about it sensation,
just you know,
a feeling.
And I thought,
I,
is there any way that package that,
you know,
is there a way to write that down so somebody could get that feeling I had in
the shower when I took things from left field,
right field and married orange with a number 12 and explained to you why it's
all really the same thing.
All right?
Could I make somebody have that experience?
So that's what I,
what I tried to do with the book and I used throughout it a lot of techniques
that I learned in hypnosis classes,
uh,
to strengthen the,
you know,
the impact.
And in the forward,
I,
I give the reader a,
you know,
plenty of clues that this is a,
a thought experiment.
It's not a typical novel.
It's not a story like there they're used to.
And what,
what were some of the techniques from hypnosis that you implemented?
Oh,
would that if I told you,
would it be a spoiler?
Um,
that's okay.
Well,
if he gives away the spotlight,
I'm just curious,
or maybe the broader question is how have you incorporated,
let me,
because I'm,
I'm a,
a,
uh,
an uninformed when it comes to hypnosis and I don't know anything about it.
It's,
I'd be just very curious how you've implemented hypnosis into your life.
I suppose.
Broader question.
Yeah.
So first of all,
um,
the way I use hypnosis is to broadly for the public,
you know,
it says most people are thinking of a stage hypnotist and something's on a
movie.
You were somebody who was programmed to kill the president.
There's something,
um,
I,
I'm not talking about any of that stuff or anything that involves a trance,
right?
I'm talking about the science of persuasion stuff that's science tested and the
things that are pretty well known and understood.
So I'll give you one example.
Just illustrate it.
My challenge,
what?
I have a book that's most of it is two people talking is that you will get
bored,
right,
right.
So I need to continually put you in the place of one of the characters.
You can't be in the place of the smartest person in the world,
you know,
because by definition,
you just can't get there.
Right.
But you can be in the place of the person who's listening to it and not buying
it.
There's no way you can buy it in it's unfinished form,
right?
It's like somebody,
it's sort of like,
um,
uh,
what's the game that you doodle?
And people try to guess your doodle,
a Pictionary,
Pictionary,
Pictionary.
So you need a certain amount of clues before anybody's going to get it right.
Nobody gets it on the first line.
So that's,
that was the experience I was going for is that,
you know,
you get it.
I completely lost my train of thought.
Thinking about Pictionary,
cause
we were out,
we were talking about persuasion and hypnosis.
Oh,
okay.
So,
right.
The method I used was,
um,
whatever the world's smartest person said something that I knew everyone reading
it with,
like,
Oh God,
there's 10 obvious reasons why that's stupid.
I would just have the person say,
I think there's that obvious reasons why that's stupid.
Um,
paraphrasing myself.
But,
uh,
another words I make,
I make my characters say the thing you just thought.
Right?
Right.
So that's a little different than traditional fiction where I'm making the
character lead you all the way.
So,
um,
so this is a technique and hypnosis you would call it pacing and leading in
persuasion.
You'd have other names for it,
but the idea is,
um,
I'm you,
so I would match you in some way.
If you were doing a standard induction,
the way you would match match,
somebody would be matching their blue breathing,
matching their level of maybe anxiety or the way they talk.
He might try to pick the same language type they use.
You know,
if somebody uses,
you know,
angry words and war words,
you'd start out using them.
That's pacing.
So you're matching them so they feel comfortable with you.
They bond with you.
They link to you,
your,
your brain's kind of become like psychologically linked,
you know,
if one person pulls the other one feels the tug,
right?
Just the way any relationship is right.
It's just the normal way to any two people act when they're together.
So,
so all you're doing is setting up a thing where you're pacing and then that sets
them up for the leading because the leading in this case in something so
outrageously unexpected that um,
without the,
the leading,
you know,
I could never take them to the new place.
It's like a,
it's,
it's a lot like judo actually in,
in so much as when you're connected to someone.
First you have to tether with the hand grips and then once you've done that,
you try to lead your opponent into a pattern that you are leading like a dance
so that you can control where they step with either foot.
And at that point you can control it.
You can control in balancing,
right?
So you can,
you can then do with them whatever you want.
Once they've kind of been trained that they're stepping pattern,
uh,
t or as,
which sounds pretty similar.
Do you know how much that makes me want to go wrestle somebody?
Right?
It's amazing.
Oh,
the foot sweeps in judo are just beautiful.
I mean,
so elegant.
You know,
I've never heard of that explanation of judo,
which instantly makes me interested in it and I had no interest whatsoever
before.
So nicely done on my pleasure.
My pleasure.
Judo is a,
especially if people search foots suites,
judo foots weaves on Youtube for instance.
It's just one of the most beautiful demonstrations
of paired physics where,
where one person is using an opponent's energy against them.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it can certainly have,
I think,
have a lot of parallels in a conversation and just human interaction.
Uh,
the,
the how are you,
how are you introduced to hypnosis?
You took this class that you had mentioned,
but what's,
uh,
what sparked your interest?
And for those people who are not familiar with hypnosis,
and I've only seen the stage performers and so on,
um,
how do you sniff out someone who is truly a master at hypnosis?
And maybe that's too broad.
Maybe they're a bunch of different types.
And how do you sniff out kind of the charlatans that you shouldn't really pay
much attention to?
Did you,
uh,
did you read my blog on Trump?
I'm not sure if you're asking.
I don't know if I have it.
I'm not,
I'm not leaving.
Okay.
So that was the most accidentally a perfect question anybody ever asks.
I say I love it.
It's,
let me start at the beginning of the,
uh,
my mother delivered,
gave birth to my little sister wall under hypnosis and did not use any
painkillers.
She did not feel pain and she was awake the whole time.
That's incredible.
Just like I left that dramatic pause after that,
but I forgot we're doing a podcast and everybody went to check their equipments.
Sorry about that.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
but I had a huge impact on me.
Um,
so it turns out our family doctor was a trained hypnotist and you know,
he,
he handled the birth and he just offered her that option.
Now,
let me be quick to point out that there's sort of a rule of one in five and
hypnosis and that is that one in five people are,
are able to go into a,
um,
a state that is that extreme.
In other words,
somebody who could simply block pain or somebody who could see something that
wasn't really in the room.
Now keep in mind that all of these cases,
these people are completely aware and awake and they can stop the sensation any
way they want,
anytime they want.
But you know,
if you're giving birth,
you're not going to be going out of your way to stop the sensation of stopping
pain.
Right?
So,
so it's not,
nobody's controlling you.
It's more like a coach working with a,
you know,
an elite player to coach is not doing it.
The coach is saying,
you know,
hey,
crossover gibble,
you know,
go into your lake,
left jog,
right?
So that a huge impact on me.
And so it got me interested in that and other things.
And so when it was in my twenties and I realized that a guy who works at us bank
teller and has drives a car,
which a one girlfriend,
uh,
affectionately,
oh,
she had a terrible name for it,
but I can't say it on the air.
Of course you can say it.
I realize there's a reason not because it's a profanity,
I just can't say.
Okay,
no problem.
Just to trade my,
I had a hand me down van from my mom and the backseats were stolen so all my
coworkers started calling it the molester mobile.
That was the next day from
my car.
Okay.
Went on the car.
Uh,
so anyway,
I thought I needed edge,
you know,
career wise,
dating wise.
And if there's anything to this,
at the very least,
I'm terribly curious about what it is and what it isn't.
And you know,
you figure your mother's not going to lie to you about childbirth.
I mean,
now it's something that became like a central story of your youth,
you know,
so it was kind of a big deal.
It doesn't seem like the thing she would've made up sort of credibility was
high.
And I thought,
well,
let me check this thing out.
But I again,
20% of the people can have that kind of experience.
And the family doctor obviously you become trained and quickly identifying who
those people are so he knew,
um,
but all the rest of the people can get a substantial benefits.
So unfortunately I'm,
I'm in the,
you know,
the 80% that can't get those extreme benefits,
but the,
the stuff I could get is immense.
Um,
and it includes the ability to,
uh,
craft the book the way I did that.
It includes a lot of technique I use for making Dilbert popular.
For example.
Um,
the reason Dilbert has no last name,
the reason you don't know what town he lives in,
you don't know the name of his company.
And here's a first for a comic strip.
I think that the second main character is the boss in terms of,
you know,
time on,
on screen,
uh,
and he doesn't have any name at all.
And that all that all comes out of a hypnosis training.
And what I do is I allow the reader to imbue the characters with as much of what
they love as they possibly can without giving them a hard stop.
So in other words,
if I said,
uh,
this is a Dilbert Goldberg,
all right?
All of the,
you know,
the antisemites would say,
well,
you know,
I don't really relate to that Goldberg guy.
Now you know,
any name,
you give them somebody,
somebody's going to be a hater,
right?
So you're,
you're taking people out of the equation.
As soon as you name him,
maybe it's the name they've heard of,
or there's a reason why it's Dilbert and not Bob,
you know,
existing association.
So all of that is just classic.
A well understood hypnosis training.
But again,
I'm not,
I'm not hypnotizing the audience.
I'm simply giving them a better product.
So keep in mind that when I talk about hypnosis,
I include things like,
um,
you know,
negotiating,
obviously selling marketing,
but also design product design.
Sorry to pause you,
but I just love to ask because I think like most people,
when I think hypnosis,
I think trance for the purpose of overcoming pain,
being as stiff as a board between she chairs,
et Cetera.
What,
how would you define hypnosis then in this case?
Cause I'm,
I'm listening to what you're describing and I'm like,
wow,
okay.
You've elements if like the,
uh,
narrative structure,
storytelling,
persuasion,
negotiation,
it covers a lot of basis.
How do you define hypnosis?
So the simplest,
um,
but I think everybody has ends up with their own definition of it if they,
if they have any with it because I don't think there's any one definition
everybody's going to agree with.
For me it is a,
for me a connection with either one person or if you're doing it,
you know,
to a group,
if you're trying to persuade a group,
you're,
you're connecting to the group,
you're getting this sort of,
you know,
pacing and leading thing going on,
you're building trust and then you're using,
uh,
usually words are sort of the programming language,
you know,
if you will.
Linguistics are the,
the user interface for this moist a robot that we are.
Um,
so if you want to program you had you pick words,
um,
if any of you saw a recent went viral recently,
there was an article in the onion in which it was just as funny article about a
couple who allegedly,
uh,
use their complete despair and hopelessness as the thing that bound bound them
together,
uh,
at,
but it was,
it was masterfully written thing.
I wish I could,
you know,
uh,
tell you the writer's name,
but the choice of words puts you in a completely different mental state.
It's just the most brilliant word choice in a piece of writing.
You'll see.
And I tried to do that too.
So what I'm writing,
and I don't know if you use the same method,
there's,
I write in layers.
So you know,
there's this first draft,
second draft,
but somewhere toward the end,
the final layer,
I look at every word I use and I say is there is a word that will work on an
emotional level or a different level or just a more perfect level.
Something that will make you remember it.
Something that'll keep you awake.
That means exactly the same thing.
So here's an example.
If I said to the audience,
and I,
I do this in front of crowds,
so you know,
you a home can play along and shout out the answer,
but I already know the answer.
I'm going to give you two words that mean about the same.
You tell me out loud.
And Tim,
you can play along.
Just say that.
Say the one of the two words they both made about the same.
That's the funniest one.
Which one is funnier,
Paul or Yank.
Yank.
Yeah.
And everybody,
everybody at home just said the same thing,
right?
So language does have that much specific control over the way you think.
And so,
uh,
you know,
science and a hypnosis,
uh,
it was kind of a precursor to a lot of the studies that have borne out a lot of
way hypnotist found by trial and error that you can manipulate the brain by what
people concentrate on,
what words you put in there,
what you make them focus on.
Um,
you know,
what you tied to their habits.
Uh,
there's just lots of ways that you can,
you can program the,
the,
the box.
Well,
I mean language is,
is mind control,
right?
I mean you can,
you can very easily make people think any number of things are fueling the
number of things by using this of symbology that we've,
that we've created known as language and I've,
I've just been so fascinated by that for so long.
Do you find then is writing an indirect way of developing the skill sets that
would make you a fast learner in hypnosis or or do they not,
does not really pore
over that cleanly?
I would say that learning to be a writer,
you're only going to maybe brush accidentally on the level that I'm even talking
about.
Got It.
Like everybody knows,
hey that's a good word,
but you,
you need to go to the next level.
You know,
if you're saying to yourself,
I am putting together a logical argument and this word is the perfect word for
my argument because it means the best thing.
Cause remembering my,
my example,
Yank and pull are really the same thing,
are they?
No,
they're not.
Right.
Because you've got a different sense and that's why one was funnier,
you know,
but it also had a y in it and had a k in it.
So there had two levels of funding this built into the word.
So I will consciously make a choice to get rid of,
have a more accurate word to instill,
to put in a word that has more of a programming control,
right?
Because you want people to have an experience because that's what they're going
to remember.
They're not going to remember what word choice you use.
This dovetails exactly into my loud defense of Donald Trump's methods,
which I've been writing about all we've got the Internet,
I've seen,
I've seen some of that.
Some of the fireworks.
So please,
uh,
let me draw a line for you that um,
I'll say an advanced,
this is conspiracy,
uh,
talk,
you know,
conspiracy theory talk.
So you,
so you don't have to say it.
None of the listeners have to tell me that.
So it's just for fun.
But there is a connection between Donald Trump and me.
There is an individual between us.
That individual happens to be the father of hypnosis.
Milton Erickson,
Nokia Ericsson,
Bill Erickson.
I'm a name known only to people who studied hypnosis usually or psychology.
So he was a linguist who put a lot of this.
Uh,
I'm not sure if he was a linguist,
but he put a lot of this stuff together,
mostly by instinct.
I think in the beginning,
one of his,
um,
and his school is the school of hypnosis that I ended up going to.
It was a different school with a few differences,
but basically I grew out of that also and have the Ericksons school is,
um,
a couple of people with John Grinder,
I think,
hope I didn't get the name wrong,
who developed a NLP neuro linguistic programming,
which is the way to use a largely words as a programming language,
although they don't market it that way though NLP is marketed with a lot of
stuff that I don't buy into,
but there's a core of it that comes from hypnosis,
which matches pretty exactly with what,
uh,
scientific studies and,
you know,
current psychology would expect.
Right?
So there's,
there's a part of it that's real strong and powerful,
but it's probably the minority of it.
I mean,
most of it is,
you know,
people being stiff as boards between two chairs and,
that sort of stuff.
Uh,
now the best practice,
or most famous practitioner of NLP,
NLP,
the person who got his inspiration from it is Tony Robbins,
Tony Robbins.
It has been,
um,
a business associate with Donald Trump.
They worked together on some kind of program about success.
You can see their videos of them talking one after another.
If you Google them,
you see them standing together on Google images,
et cetera.
Now,
I have no reason to believe that they ever had a conversation on the methods of
persuasion.
I think Trump is first of all,
a natural cause he's,
he's been doing it for a long time.
But if you look at his recent work that has Erickson's fingerprints,
all the,
all over it.
Let me give you an example,
and I wrote about this.
So if you want to see the details is that,
you know,
dilbert.com and my blog,
but,
uh,
take the debate where he came in as the under prepared buffoon who is going to
blow himself up.
And Megan Kelly of Fox News decided that yes,
that's exactly what was going to happen.
And she started right out with the,
uh,
did you say all these bad things about women?
Now every other politician would have been smeared off the stage by that because
it wouldn't matter what he said back,
right.
It wouldn't matter what the response was because the question itself,
like it helped me.
Yeah,
the question is the content.
All right.
The logic of the answer,
the,
you know,
maybe somebody said,
oh that was taken out of context or whatever,
which is what people usually say and it usually is.
I mean that's actually usually true,
but the,
the public isn't going to hear that.
They're just going to hear the feeling that they felt when Megan Kelly said that
person's name bad to women and let us really liked the beginning and the end of
the thinking for,
you know,
let's say at least 20% of the public,
right about the same 20% that can easily be hypnotized coincidentally.
So,
but what did Trump do?
As soon as that question came up,
he sent my,
interrupted her and he said only Rosie O'donnell that my friends is hypnosis.
He took an anchor that everybody can visualize and his core audience already had
a negative impression.
They're negative.
Impression of Rosie O'donnell almost certainly was bigger,
stronger,
and visual and more important than whatever Megan Kelly just said,
which should have been a full house.
I mean,
she,
she showed him for kings and he beat her hand and he did it without even trying.
And he did it with a method which is well understood,
right?
This is a negotiating technique.
You know,
you throw it out an anchor,
you divert everybody.
And so instead of becoming this,
you know,
sexist,
which he could have been on day one,
he became the straight talker.
He's the guy,
he and,
and he admitted in the very next sentence that he'd also said bad things about
other women.
See,
he has some really interesting,
oh,
but wait,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
Wait.
There.
There's a better part.
It gets better.
I'm ready now.
I know you follow the headlines.
So you know what happened next?
Roger Ailes and Fox News.
Um,
you know,
Wade in say like,
we're going to need to make peace,
right,
with Donald Trump because,
um,
you know,
this is getting out of hand and Donald Trump made peace with them.
How do you interpret that?
I'll tell you how I interpreted it.
I interpret it as Donald Trump just bought fox news without paying a frikken
penny because if he wants that,
if they want him to appear on his show,
that's up to him.
And he just proved he doesn't need him.
So he's going to get all the press he was without Fox News.
If they want to get out of the program and support the guy who is probably going
to be the nominee,
that's,
that's what I've predicted.
Um,
because of his knee hypnosis skills in particular having nothing to do with his
policies.
By the way,
I'll get to that.
I,
you know,
I'm not a,
not a fan of the policies,
but I don't think he is either.
You just,
you know,
they're opening,
negotiating gambits as,
as he does.
So he effectively,
um,
change the debate,
became the straight talker,
took control of Fox News all in one day.
And all of that is straight out of,
you know,
the hypnotist playbook,
although it's,
you know,
he would call it persuasion.
He might call it negotiating.
He literally wrote the book,
the art of the deal.
Let me show you this to again.
So you see the pattern.
So if you saw his immigration plan,
that's like the most ridiculous thing in the world.
It's like they'll all the giant fence make Mexico pay for it as if they want to
do that.
Round up 11 million Mexicans who have been in the country for a loyal and
sending it back,
change the constitution to get rid of the birthright.
All right,
I'm saying it with my mock invoice,
but um,
you know,
then I'm going to reverse it around and tell you that if you,
if,
if you evaluate him as a politician,
which is what the political writers are all doing incorrectly right now,
that's the most ridiculous bag of shit anybody ever proposed to the country
because as no chance of happening in that form,
right?
It's just not going to happen.
But is not a politician.
He's a businessman and he say have the test and he just gave you an anchor.
And his anchor is,
look at what I'm going to do.
Everybody get excited.
Let's talk about changing the constitution.
Let's talk about the cost and the and the heartbreak and the,
and the misery that would cause to these 11 million people.
I'm planning to.
I'm proposing we kick out of the country.
Let's talk about how expensive that fence is.
And then when he gets to negotiate with Congress,
guess what?
It gives off.
He gives away,
cause the only thing he wanted was the fence,
right?
The only thing he wanted was the fence.
But can you say in your plan,
I'm going to give everybody a free pass after we build the fence.
No,
because that makes it immigration explode for the 10 years that takes you to
build a fence.
So you have to get there.
The way he got there,
and it's a way a businessman would do it.
You come in with this ridiculous first offer.
You'd make all the idiots in the media who think is a politician,
even though he screams of these dot.
I mean he wrote a book on this stuff.
You know,
it was a number,
I think it was a number one bestseller,
right?
He could not be more clear or more honest about what he's doing as he does it,
but it's still visible because you're looking at him as a politician and saying,
if his goal is to do this thing as a stupid goal,
he's not going to kick out an 11 million people.
Nobody's going to,
nobody's going to go for that.
That's not the game and will never be in the game.
I almost guarantee you that if he gets approval to build the fence,
you'll probably get some Mexican funding now.
Completely that an enough,
it'll be enough to say,
look,
nobody else was even good.
Ask for half.
Right.
All right,
I got you.
Half of is paid for.
If he does that,
people that are going to wet their pants,
right,
and then he's going to say,
I guarantee it.
I guarantee you.
He's going to say then now this imagines he gets nominated and becomes president
and so I guess I can't guarantee anything,
but,
but if it got to the situation,
the likely outcome would be that you'd say,
look,
yeah,
that 11 million people.
Yeah,
I guess it would be hard to round them up.
Why don't we say that if you stay in a jail for x number of years,
you pay your taxes,
you register,
you do some useful things that,
uh,
you know,
we'll make an exception in your case just for practicality because that's what a
business person does.
And by the way,
I've got my fence built now.
My brand brand America is exclusive for the first time.
And that's why you hired me.
You hired me to be a brand manager in a hire me to,
you know,
to tell the truth on my first offer.
You offered me to negotiate.
He's,
he's literally running for the office of negotiator in chief and practicing his
craft.
And he's doing it with such brilliance that I've,
I've literally,
I don't think I've ever seen anybody do it this well except,
oh,
I can think of one other person.
Um,
let's see.
there was Bill Clinton who also is a good friends of Tony Robbins.
I love the web.
It's like six,
six degrees of Kevin Bacon.
Yeah.
And by the way,
and so I'll say this at the end cause I went on for awhile.
Uh,
I'm not suggesting that there's a grand conspiracy there.
Um,
it's a fact that all those things are connected.
That doesn't mean that you know,
the,
the influences running through them in some one way direction.
Like I described,
if you use as a,
as a possible one of your filters to explain what's going on with the Trump
campaign,
I just read it in the news,
a writer saying essentially nobody understands why he's rising in the polls.
And I'm saying exactly.
And you won't understand either.
Yeah.
I think it's also hard sometimes for people,
particularly in the day to day news cycle,
just the churn of constant noise with the hours that need to be sold on TV and
pages that need to be filled in newspapers that you need attention.
Right?
It's kind of like the,
the um,
Glen Gary,
Glen Ross,
Alec Baldwin,
you know,
always be closing speech with the like,
attention,
interest,
desire,
action.
Like you have to have the attention first and,
and Donald Trump is very good at doing that.
The,
the other technique that I'd never seen,
and he uses it all the time,
but it doesn't seem to lose its efficacy.
It's one of these sort of guilty until proven innocent approaches or it's a
retort,
uh,
which is he'll say,
check your facts.
Next question.
And so with any journalists and it throws them off balance just enough cause
they're like,
oh shit.
Like did my researchers miss,
you know,
the one citation that refuted everything that I'm actually
laying on this particular person.
And so whether it's,
uh,
you know,
Matt Lauer or anyone else would be like,
Matt,
check your facts.
Next question.
And it's just,
they're as good as dead.
It's one of those,
it's,
it's brilliant and it's in,
in a way,
and that's not to say that I would want,
you know,
Donald Trump running the country,
but it's,
I do admire the,
the,
so the Ringman ship,
let me,
let me wait on that for a moment.
Look how many ways that could have been done incorrectly.
Suppose he simply said,
Matt,
your facts are wrong.
That's right.
Totally.
Doesn't work.
Totally different.
Yeah,
totally different.
Check your facts is what I call the,
uh,
the high ground maneuver,
which I also write about.
Um,
it's the same thing.
Jobs did what he explained to way antennagate just by saying all smartphones
have problems.
Um,
we're trying to make our customers happy.
He made a national story go away.
And uh,
less than 30 seconds with those two sentences,
uh,
be took the high ground and everybody said,
oh,
wait a minute,
we've been talking about you.
Well,
yeah,
I guess,
I guess that's just got a normal,
when you think about smart phones and I'm sure glad I have a smart phone.
So I guess that's just normal.
So what Trump dud,
if you said your facts are wrong,
then he set the world Matt Lauer Against Donald Trump and anybody who like Matt
Lauer better than Donald Trump,
the other go to side with them.
But instead he said,
check your facts.
He said,
I'm a person with more information,
which actually seems pretty consistent because like it says world,
right?
Like we were talking about his facts.
It's not Matt Lauer's facts.
Matt Lauer's guy who studied up 10 minutes before the interview.
So you say you say that to me and I just laugh and say,
okay,
I don't know what the truth is here,
Donald,
but probably you're right,
right.
It's just brilliant.
It's really,
really clever.
I want to shift gears just for a second because I love this type of
deconstruction and I'd love to chat a little bit about goals versus systems and
just to hear you perhaps talk about some of how you think about your life in
those terms or not.
Yes.
Um,
you want me to just jump right in and define those two things?
That'd be,
that'd be very helpful.
So the,
um,
was ribbon my book,
how to fail at almost everything and still win big.
And the idea is that if you have a goal,
I'm goal oriented approach to the world.
That that's an approach that made perfect sense 200 years ago.
If you were a farmer and you had a simple operation than you thought,
if you cleared another 10 acres before winter or you could grow more corn,
you are almost certainly right.
So clearing those 10 acres before winter was a perfectly good goal and it made
perfect sense to pursue it.
But now,
fast forward.
All right?
It's a,
it's a,
it's a modern times.
There's probably more technology,
more complexity in your pocket right now and your smartphone than the farmer hat
and his entire operation.
All right?
Today,
if you're focused on one thing for more than a minute and a half,
there's a good chance that that thing is no longer worth having.
All right?
There are people going to school for degrees that won't mean anything even four
years from now when they retire or when they get to school.
Um,
so you've got people who were making plans with a clear focus in a world that no
longer supports a clear path to anything.
So what's the alternative?
And in a world where you can't,
if you can't predict the future.
And on top of that,
even if you could predict it and you pick the goal and you marched straight at
it when you got there,
there's a really good chance that you had said,
you know,
I didn't notice there were five other goals that were way better than this one
because they emerged while you were focusing on your goal.
Right?
So if you're not keeping your eye on the and the whole of it,
and if you're not playing the odds and you're picking a,
you know,
a moon shot as your way to go through life,
you're going to feel like you're failing.
Not only if you miss the mood,
but you're going to feel like a failure all the way to the moon because you
haven't gotten the moon yet and you're not quite sure if you're going to get
there.
So what's better than that?
Um,
and by the way,
I still recommend goals hardly for simple situations.
So if you enter a bowling tournament,
your goal list of when the bowling tournament,
right?
It's a simple situation.
And usually when it's a like a human made a construct,
they are simplified and therefore a goal.
It makes sense.
Here's what may not make sense.
Let's say you said,
my goal is to get my boss's job.
It's a pretty common goal,
right?
That's stupid because your boss's job is just one of the many things that could
be better than what you're doing now.
And the chances are there's other way better than that.
Yeah.
Your boss's boss's job,
for example.
You know,
what are you doing about that?
You know?
Um,
how about some job at another company about a lateral move that gets you in a
better place to go higher later.
You know?
So as soon as you focus,
you've given yourself something to fail at and you close yourself out from the
other opportunities.
All right?
So,
um,
what I write about instead is what I call a systems way of looking at the world
in which you are continually looking at ways to improve your odds in some
favorable area,
some favorable,
a focus,
you know,
without being too specific.
Um,
so your area might be,
you know,
business or art or whatever it is.
Um,
so,
uh,
the,
the hallmark of a good system is that even as things are failing,
you're still improving your odds and your personal worth.
All right?
So if for example,
uh,
I start up a company and it doesn't work,
I would say,
oh,
I had a goal and I started that little startup and avail that none of the
failure.
But if I started a company that was in a field that I already work and um,
let's say making all the contacts that I made through the startup,
uh,
that networking,
the things I learned made me more valuable in the things,
you know,
maybe day job or
the next job I do.
Then I came out of hat.
So that's the system limit.
Let me give you a kind of a non business example of that.
Um,
I had a friend in high school who ordered to have a girlfriend and I wanted to
have a girlfriend,
but he had a,
he had kind of a systems approach.
It.
I had a goal approach,
my goal approaches,
I'd pick out the,
uh,
the prettiest looking girl in my class.
And I'd say,
this,
this girl must be by girlfriend.
I will do everything I can to make this happen,
not do my research.
I'm figuring out who her friends were,
where I can hang out and,
and,
you know,
it might take me months and at the end of it,
it usually ended this way,
right.
She'd say,
you know,
one of two things.
Either she had a boyfriend,
so I've wasted three months.
Or she'd say,
I don't like you,
then I've wasted three months.
But every once in a while she'd say,
Hey,
you know,
this didn't happen often.
But once in a while she'd say,
I have a boyfriend and I don't like you.
So that was my experience with Lego.
So by my friend,
even if I didn't have a boyfriend.
Right?
Um,
so
my best story of rejection in seventh grade was asking the prettiest girl,
uh,
the dance the first time ever asked somebody to slow dance.
And she said,
uh,
you know,
it's too hot.
I'd rather not.
And I said,
perhaps if you took off your down winter jacket.
And she said,
um,
and I'm also too tired.
All right.
So,
so that,
that was,
that was by dating experience in high school.
That was a goal oriented approach.
Right.
So my friend Mandwell,
he had a different approach.
He had a systems approach.
He would simply go wherever there were plenty of girls and he would ask them in
order of descending,
descending order of looks,
will you be my girlfriend?
And or some version of that.
Of course,
almost everybody said no.
Now you're probably thinking,
oh,
you're telling me the old story about keep trying,
you know,
get back on the horse.
I'm not telling you that story at all.
I'm telling you,
he was learning a skill while I was wasting my time.
That guy knows how to approach strangers.
He knows what works,
what doesn't.
He's got a thicker skin.
Um,
and he also had a lot of girlfriends,
so he was learning a lot that way as well.
But so,
so he,
he was failing in a way that puts them ahead no matter what happened.
I was failing in a way that didn't put me ahead.
It just made me feel like a loser and probably put me behind for the next time.
I want her to feel confident in front of someone else.
Um,
so,
and I can give you more examples from say fitness and diet because I know some
people have asked about that,
but they leave.
They would love to hear this.
Definitely.
So A,
a goal oriented approach and let's say a diet would be,
I want to lose 10 pounds and I'm going to do it with my willpower.
I'm going to keep those cookies out of my mouth.
I'm going to put the fork down and I'm going to push away from the table or I'm
just going to try harder because whiteness quiet right now.
Everybody who's been alive for more than 10 minutes knows that that can work in
the short run,
but it just
doesn't work in the long run.
You need something else assessed them.
So here's a system that I've been using that has me in the best shape of my life
at 58 and uses no willpower or whatsoever.
I eat whatever I want,
whenever I want to.
It's just that,
ah,
my system is education.
I go out of my way.
If I see an article that says new thing,
uh,
discovered about the link between this food that most of that I can ignore.
But every once in a while you see something that says,
um,
you know,
he just,
uh,
eat more protein and less of those simple carbs.
Uh,
good things will happen.
And you say,
okay,
I already knew that one.
How deep does this knowledge thing go and how much difference does it make?
Well,
uh,
let me,
let me give you an example.
Say you and I go to the salad bar and um,
it's a terrible salad bar.
All there is is a white potato,
plain russet potato and some plain pasta.
And we're both trying to watch our weight.
All right.
What do you get?
Do you get the potato or the pasta?
Now I asked this question in life,
uh,
crowds and it's about evenly split it to half the people,
but mostly people don't know.
There's only a few people in the whole room.
We even know the answer and the answer is actually really clear.
It turns out that the put the white potato as opposed to the sweet potatoes that
are not bad,
the white potato has a terrible glycaemic index.
The pasta probably should,
but there's something about the way it processes that isn't fully understood
that it just does.
So,
you know,
pasta isn't the best food in the world if you're trying to look into watch your
weight.
But if you had no choice of only those two,
I pick the pasta.
You picked a potato,
you're struggling with your willpower,
eating like crazy and then having a good time.
Because I've only,
I've learned which foods I can eat like crazy and uh,
not stimulate cravings.
So if I eat the simple carbs for lunch,
I know I'm just going to be hungrier later.
I've learned that,
um,
sometimes sleep pretends to be the same feeling as hunger.
So if I haven't slept,
I say,
oh,
I'm not really hungry and stop eating.
You know,
I need to either take a nap or I can eat some peanuts because I've read and I've
experienced this.
I know it's true that if he had fat things,
they have a lot of calories and that parts great.
Maybe if you tried to watch your weight,
but they have such a good impact on reducing your,
uh,
your cravings because fat's good at doing that.
They will make up for it in long run.
And by the way,
it's full of protein and goodness and you know,
it's not bad to you peanuts.
So the other thing I do is a process to avoid using willpower is that it would
be impossible for me I think to stop eating.
Um,
both the quantity that I want to eat.
You know,
the food,
cause sometimes you just gotta shovel a lot in your face.
You just,
you know,
you just got to eat a lot and sometimes you want to eat the thing you want to
eat.
So sometimes it's about the flavor and the taste and sometimes it's,
yeah,
just need a lot of food.
So I allow myself to have a lot of food anytime I want that.
I don't put any control on that.
I just make sure that it's the kind of food you can eat forever and you know,
you're not regretted.
Uh,
you know,
it's could
be salads and yogurts and fruits and vegetables,
mostly raw stuff.
And if I think I'm overdoing it a little bit.
Dot.
I'll throw in some peanuts or some,
uh,
you know,
roasted,
uh,
you know,
creamed almonds or something.
And you are a vegetarian.
Is that,
is that right?
Or have you have been mostly I tried to introduce fish that my diet,
but I'm having a hard time with it cause I can't,
I can't get past the,
the icky factor.
Um,
that's just personal.
I liked it.
I just can't get past it.
So in my case,
I use zero willpower,
right?
And one by one I have picked off things at which were problem cravings such as
diet coke.
I was drinking,
I somewhere between 10 and 20 a day.
I think of Diet for years,
30 years probably.
Uh,
now if I said to myself,
today's the day I'm going to go on a healthy eating diet and diet coke was just
one of the 45 things I was depriving myself off,
it would be pretty tough.
But instead I say to myself,
I could eat everything I want all day long.
I get a drink,
whatever I want,
as long as that's on the good list,
there's just one thing I can't do today.
Just one thing,
right?
And still thinks a little willpower.
But I noticed that after about a month or so,
two months really to be cleaned,
the craving goes away.
And today,
you know,
a couple of years later,
I look at a diet coke and it's actually hard to wrap my head around the thought
that I would want to put that in my body.
It's just looks like a total bunch of chemicals.
So cravings can be completely managed if you,
if you isolate them and pick them out of the herd and you know,
don't put too much of a willpower burden on yourself at the same time.
Now,
the downside of course is this,
the stakes,
you know,
several years instead of,
everybody wants to lose 10 pounds in a month and I don't have any solution for
you if you,
if you know,
if that's what you want to do.
Now having said all this,
I'll also say that everybody's different.
And my good friend and startup partner,
uh,
Quinn Harker,
he will run a marathon and you know,
go ride his bike and go for a swim after that iron man.
And for him,
the challenge and the pain and the willpower is actually part of the attraction.
Right?
So that's,
that's part of what it brings it to them.
So it's no,
no surprise.
His weight is perfect.
Yes.
Keep in mind that whatever you hear from me,
it doesn't apply to everybody.
Um,
so the,
the other part of the system is finding,
experimenting continually.
And I know you're into this,
um,
experimenting and trying to isolate one thing and saying,
okay,
I do this for a week.
Did that make any difference than anything?
Absolutely.
I mean the tracking and it's when it's,
you underscore a few things.
The first is that,
uh,
you have become better identifying alternate causes for say hunger,
right?
You didn't sleep enough,
et cetera.
And for instance,
many people who cuts refined carbohydrates and starchy carbohydrates from your
diet will feel like they want carbs,
whereas in fact they're just dehydrated because when you cut carbohydrates,
you retain water.
So very simple fix for a lot of people is to put some sea salt or sprinkle a
little salt into their drinking water,
uh,
just into a few cups a day,
which then eradicates these types of carb cravings about branch chain amino
acids could do the same thing sometimes,
but the,
uh,
the,
just to touch on the,
the goals versus systems.
So I find for myself that I approach it in a,
in a very similar way.
And I'd love to ask you about your MBA program in a second,
but when I,
I decided I would not go to an MBA program,
but I had fantasized about going to Stanford GSB,
uh,
graduate school of business for many,
many,
many years.
And I always thought that was kind of where I was,
I should have gone Undergrad,
et cetera.
And uh,
at the,
at the end of it decided that I would take what that would have cost over two
years and invest in startup investments.
This was in 2007,
right after the four hour workweek had come out and decided that I,
I would,
I would invest based on the assumption that I would lose it all,
but that I would try to optimize for skill acquisition.
Yeah.
There you go.
And so when I make decisions these days,
whether it's a TV show or the four hour chef and trying new distribution with
Amazon,
even if everything goes sideways,
I try to stack the deck.
And usually that's kind of the WHO,
what,
where,
why.
And when rundown,
like a journalist,
I'll be like,
who am I doing this right?
Let me optimize the people I'm interacting with so that I can acquire as many
skills or abilities as possible.
Uh,
you know,
when and where,
if I can be a novel environment.
So let me try to optimize for that,
et cetera.
So that I'll have this goal.
And it's usually a big audition audacious goal of sometime,
even if that feels like the four hour chef was boycotted by almost every
retailer on the planet because it came out of Amazon publishing and I was
prepared for that,
uh,
and that then allowed me to do experiments with bit torrent and so on.
So I came out of it not entirely happy with missing the goal.
Of course I'm very competitive,
but the,
there were skills that then carried over to future projects.
So I,
I,
I also view sort of my decisions in a very,
very similar way.
Not to say it's the only way,
but I find having both to be very helpful for me.
Yeah.
I would,
uh,
kind of summarize that by saying that the product is always yourself.
Right,
right,
right.
As soon as you lose sight of that,
that you're,
um,
you're working a 14 hour day,
you're sacrificing your health.
I mean,
you probably did all those things too,
but the path is to do less of that and take care of your health and maximize
your,
your instrument.
What,
uh,
what was the first time you were paid for Dilbert?
Like received payment for Dilbert?
Um,
it was after being syndicated and then waiting several months for the,
um,
the accounting to work through the system and that probably 1989,
1989 I got,
I'm just having trouble doing the math here.
Roughly how old were you at the time?
Let's see.
Oh,
are we going to do math in public?
But that is a social,
so you were like 30,
late thirties,
I think the,
is that right?
Early,
early,
early thirties,
early thirties.
And were you at,
uh,
PAC bell at the time or had you already left?
I was at pack bell and stayed there after Dilbert was in newspapers for about
eight years.
Well,
I stayed there for several years after Dilbert,
but eight years in total.
And was was that surely to get the income from cartooning to a point where you
could,
you could,
uh,
you could survive on that or were there other reasons that you stayed at that
job for,
for eight years?
I hate to say skill acquisition,
but that's really a big part of the answer.
I was working in the technology lab,
um,
you know,
in those years when the Internet was new,
literally the first person I knew who heard the word Internet,
you know,
outside of my work friends.
Um,
so we were learning things that I knew had,
you know,
huge impact on my future and I didn't want to kind of lose that,
that foot in it.
Uh,
and that actually became critical for the success of Dilbert later cause Dilbert
became the first syndicated comic on the Internet back when that seemed like a
silly idea.
So someone was at,
but,
uh,
what I say skills acquisition that I'm counting on the fact that I was getting
most of my fodder for the cartoon from my actual experiences and what coworkers
were suggesting.
So I had that going.
But,
um,
yes,
I mean,
I,
I waited until I knew I could do it financially,
but it continued weighted waiting long after that because of the skill
acquisition and also because the pain of working completely goes away when you
don't need to do it.
Right.
It's like a,
it's like dealing with a small children,
right?
It's,
it's as long as you're not forcing them to do something,
uh,
the likelihood of it happening goes,
goes way up.
But,
but think of,
you know,
just the simple example where in the real world will real work world.
I'll say,
I'm going to try doing x.
Oh my God,
if x doesn't work,
my career,
my promotions by everything.
But now,
but after I didn't need to be there.
I could just say that.
What's better?
X or y x,
your mind is free.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
uh,
I think something that is commonly misinterpreted with say,
some of the writing that I've done is people are like,
oh,
I should just quit everything and throw hail Mary and sort of jump off the cliff
and learn to fly on the way down.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
They keep,
you can keep your,
keep your current Gig,
do this on the weekends,
do this early in the morning,
uh,
moonlight.
And then you can decide where on the spectrum you want to be,
whether you want to have both jobs.
You were wanting to do one
20% of the time,
but there's no need to sort of put all of your eggs in one basket right at the
outset.
What was dog barks?
Original name.
So before dog Burt was published,
uh,
he was a doodle that I would draw on my whiteboard in my cubicle at Pacific Bell
and before that at the Crocker National Bank and I had a no contest.
The name,
the characters.
And uh,
the name Gilbert was named by a friend of mine,
Mike Goodwin,
who didn't know,
he had seen it in a world war two cartoon that was at the same name,
Dilbert.
And I found out about that after it got published.
I wouldn't to use the name,
but it's lucky I did.
And I guess the original Creator,
uh,
didn't have a problem with it cause he never contacted me.
But because I had this character Dilbert and he was the type of guy who would be
a loader and I wanted to give him a dog just so there was somebody to interact
with.
And then one of the name of the dog to have some correspondence with Dilbert.
And so dog Burt's original name was delta.
Okay.
Now did he ever made,
did he,
did he ever make it into a strip with the name Dell dog or no,
no.
I wisely decided that was not a good commercial decision.
At least offered newspapers cause they're all,
you know,
aggressively rated g.
What's,
uh,
what aspects of Dilbert changed,
besides that in the sort of gestational period or when you were testing out new
characters on the white board and so on?
Well,
in the beginning their characters or I'm not really formed.
So you know,
you've got an idea who they are and maybe you're thinking of somebody else,
what do you write it?
But over time they become,
um,
some part of me,
you know,
there,
they each represent a different voice of my head.
You know,
Dilbert's got to the voice of reason.
And,
you know,
the one that you know is uh,
oh,
say he's challenged by,
you know,
he loves a challenge.
He likes fixing things more than the likes.
You know,
talking to people and social interactions and stuff.
The dog,
Bert is the,
the evil part of my brain.
The little voice in my head that is saint just the worst things when I made it
otherwise polite conversation.
And,
you know,
it's the,
it's the voice that's trying to keep me from not laughing or,
or forcing me to tell a bad joke suddenly.
So I have a reason to laugh at myself,
really covering up that I'm thinking something horrible.
Uh,
so yeah,
he's,
he's the worst part of me.
You know,
my Megalomania and my,
you know,
my,
uh,
lack of regard for other humans,
which,
you know,
obviously it's an exaggeration.
I've,
I have plenty of regard for other humans,
but not always their intelligence.
So dog,
dog,
it takes that role.
And you've done,
uh,
I mean,
you,
you've had a massively successful career,
obviously.
Dope.
It is done spectacularly well.
I've heard that one of the,
one of the innovative things you did have many was including your email address
in your panels.
Is that,
uh,
do you think that had a huge impact and what other types of decisions do you
think helped a Dilbert to become the success that it became?
So there were several key things that happened and this will dovetail back to a
conversation about luck.
But,
um,
when we first contemplating putting deliver on the Internet,
that that in itself looked like a huge risky thing because my god,
you can't give away your content that we're selling to other people right in
front of their noses as we're selling it to them.
I mean,
it sounded,
it sounded crazy that right today it's just as normal business.
Right?
Um,
but that it seemed like a big risky thing.
Likewise,
what I decided to see if I could get better user input,
um,
using the things I'd learned in my Berkeley Mba classes.
Um,
I did what no cartoonist had ever done before and the sounds know stupid and
trivial when you say it from today's perspective.
But I opened a channel directly to my customers.
So normally what happens is the cartoon is write something.
It goes to an editor who sends it to an editor at a newspaper who sends it to
production.
You know,
newspaper delivery boy gives it to the user who reads it.
I have no idea what happened after that.
Right.
I don't know if they laughed.
Cursed hated me.
So I thought,
well,
I'll do business one oh one.
I mean,
this is what I should be doing.
It's a business.
It's not art per se.
And so I ran my email address in the margins of the Strip.
A thousands of people started writing to me.
I was getting thousands of emails a day.
A lot of them said the following.
Uh,
I don't know any Belize.
Anyone else who has emails?
So I'm writing to you.
It was literally the dawn of the Internet to give you an idea how early it was
in the dawn of the Internet.
My address was my full name,
scottAdams@aol.com.
Nobody had that Nice.
I mean,
there are six people named Scott Adams in my towns.
Is that the primordial soup of the Internet days?
Right.
So,
um,
thousands of people wrote in,
but what they said was interesting.
So,
uh,
consistently they said when Dilbert is doing his office type things,
which he actually wasn't doing much in the beginning.
Mostly he was staying at home and interacting with dog bird going on dates,
but only once in a while you'd go to the office.
But it turns out people like that the most by far.
And so I pivoted.
So I changed,
delivered into a workplace strip.
And that was certainly the biggest change.
You know,
the biggest thing that made a difference.
The other was putting it on the Internet early when being early to anything made
a big difference.
And it was the right product to be on the Internet.
But it also solved our biggest marketing problem with newspapers because our
salesperson
would go into a newspaper and say,
hey,
here's a new thing.
And they'd say,
ah,
you know,
we don't get it.
We don't care in the old days.
But once I had literally thousands of email messages saying,
this is the greatest thing,
why don't you put it in my newspaper,
the,
and then they name the actual newspaper,
I printed them all out.
I collected them by what newspaper they mentioned,
sent them off,
you know,
physically like printouts to the salespeople.
And then they walked into the office of the editor and put the printout on their
desk and the editor said,
okay,
you know,
for a newspaper if five people ask for something that they've never heard of,
and it's something that they can easily,
you know,
for $20 a month they can put it in the newspaper or whatever it is,
they're going to do that.
It's true with politicians also,
just as a side note for people,
like honestly,
you get 10 people to call,
uh,
lawmakers office,
especially if they're not somebody in the news every day.
It gets a lot of attention.
That's really smart.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And let me say that about me as well.
I mean I'm,
I'm a voracious reader of all my feedback on social media as well as email and
everything else and I've changed a substantial things and the way I approach,
you know,
Dilbert or other jobs based on,
one or two emails.
What,
uh,
what other types of,
don't ask me.
Well,
uh,
I'll tell you the,
the biggest change that,
uh,
there were actually more emails than that,
a few,
but it's one that jumps to mind.
When Kapur was originally introduced,
he was just a cat.
He wasn't meant to be a regular character,
but thousands of people not going to say thousands,
I'll say probably hundreds of people emailed and said,
we love Cat Bert.
And what's interesting is he didn't have that name.
So it's a more,
I mean,
many people said capper,
but you had not given him that name.
Right.
So,
so capper now they'll comes out of nothing.
I mean,
it certainly had no plans to have a,
you know,
a Garfield competitor in that.
Now I'm stuck.
I'm like,
oh,
they all wanted it,
but what am I going to do with it?
So I have to now,
I'd moved Dilbert into the office by that time and I'm like,
ah,
how do I get a cat in the office?
It's already too much that I've got a dog there.
And then I realized that a cat's personality fits perfectly with human
resources.
So I made him the director of resources because you know,
like,
like a human resources person.
A cat doesn't really care if you live or die.
He just likes playing with you before it happens.
So,
and uh,
and recently I started working with a,
uh,
a company called does think HR who does a subscriptions of HR advice,
I guess my simple accident description.
And,
uh,
I'm working with them with cat bird as a potential way to get their message out
there.
So,
uh,
this is a good example of the systems versus the goal.
I mean,
I certainly didn't start out to have a cat cartoon.
I started out to do a bunch of things.
I introduced a lot of characters.
I washed to figure out which ones work and I just,
you know,
put water on the stuff that work.
What are some of the tools that most help you,
tools or routines that most help you cartoon these days or right for that matter
either.
Oh,
well,
I use by a Wacom Cintiq for the drawing.
So what that is,
is a,
a special,
uh,
monitor.
In my case,
it's a really big one.
I think it's a 27 inches across.
Um,
and I can draw on it directly with the stylists.
much like you had drawn paper,
although you have to learn new techniques and use Photoshop and you know,
a lot of different stuff.
So it's just Photoshop at a Syn,
synthetic a walk.
Um,
and uh,
after that it's a,
I just usually peruse the news,
drink coffee,
eat my protein bar in the morning and something jumps in my head.
And if it doesn't,
maybe I'll read a few email messages that I think we'll have messages or
suggestions.
Sometimes I'll check the suggestions coming in from various places.
Usually,
you know,
my,
uh,
I've got,
an email address just for that,
that runs in the strip every day.
So some combination of that gives me some kind of an idea or I where I jump off
of what was the last thing I wrote the day before.
Cause sometimes they lend themselves to a serial treatment.
But I,
I don't have much of a process beyond being in the right frame of boon frame of
mind physically and mentally.
Like getting rid of all the other distractions,
which is in part why I do it in the morning,
not just because my energy and my mind are better,
but because of distractions are far less.
So,
you know,
for me creativity is a process of removing barriers.
It's not so much a process of pulling something in that was outside me.
Right,
right.
It's a sort of decreasing the,
the noise to signal ratio so that what was already there is easier to put down.
Is that how you,
well actually the,
uh,
the analogy I use is it has more to do with flow rate.
That is to say,
um,
if I'm busy,
I'm thinking about lots of things.
I might have one good idea in an hour,
but if I clear my mind,
I can't stop them coming.
They're like,
bump,
bump.
Now that's the part.
Unfortunately everybody wants to know what's the secret to being,
you know,
a creative person and having a new idea every day.
And unfortunately there's just some of this that either is a bad childhood
experience or DNA.
You know,
you,
you can do a lot to make yourself better at whatever you have,
but the flow rate of ideas that I have I think probably is unnatural.
I think that's true.
I,
but I also think it's a skill that can be cultivated.
Uh,
James Aalto chair,
who's a friend of mine,
has recommended to his readers for some time to develop the habit of just
writing down 10 ideas.
I think usually in the morning,
each day.
And I've spoken to a number of people who have adopted this
habit and it's,
it's become,
um,
sort of exponentially easier over time,
uh,
to the extent that now they can't contain it to 10.
Uh,
so it's,
uh,
it's,
it is,
it is a curious question.
I mean the,
the,
the question of creativity comes up a lot,
but like you,
I have to prevent too many extraneous inputs if I want to have any type of
unique output.
And so I'd love to ask you about your question or,
or your,
your morning rather if you have full control of your day,
what is your ideal first 60 to 90 minutes look like in your day?
Like what time do you wake up?
What type of protein bar due to et cetera.
So it depends on when I went to sleep,
either five or six,
but let's say five.
I get up and uh,
I walked directly downstairs and get my coffee.
So push one button and way forward.
Have my one protein bar,
which is always the same because the coffee is always the same.
The proteins or is the same at the time's always the same.
Give or take that hour because I'm removing decisions.
What type of protein bar do you eat?
I eat a builders 20 gram protein bar,
chocolate peanut butter.
And I'm so smart that I actually picked it up and they had the label in front of
me because I expected that question.
Well,
you know,
he will.
Well
at that point I usually get on and start looking.
I guess I,
I check Twitter first,
um,
check my web page to see if the plane blew up.
That I don't know about,
you know,
did I,
did I say anything yesterday that caused the world to melt down?
Because,
you know,
I'll need to know about that.
Um,
failing that,
I usually open,
um,
business insider because I just like reading.
Usually while I'm waiting for my coffee,
I've looked at my Facebook feed and you know,
just tweeted,
you know,
played around.
Basically,
I'm just trying to wake up,
get my mind working.
And there's a process where once you clear your mind,
you have to flood it.
And you may use different words for this,
but I know you do it.
Um,
so you empty it and then you flood it with new input.
That's not the old input.
So I'm looking at the news and when he has stuff I haven't seen,
I'm not looking at yesterday's problem for the fifth time.
I'm looking at a new problem.
I'm thinking of a new idea.
So flooding in all the,
all the,
uh,
the new stuff,
but then he,
then you got to find out where in that flood is the little,
uh,
piece that's worth working with.
And that's where I,
that's where I use the body model.
I kind of cycled through all this,
this study model you said?
Yeah.
So the model is your brain can't find good content.
All right.
Not directly in an intellectual sense,
obviously the brain's involved,
but what I mean is that as I'm thinking of these ideas and they're floating
through my head,
um,
I'm monitoring my body.
I'm not monitoring my mind and when my body changes,
I have something that other are gonna care about too.
Oh,
that's cool.
I like that.
So that means posture or what or what type of indicators are there?
Um,
I'll tell you when,
if I'm thinking of let's say a particular setup for a joke,
I'll,
I'll think of the joke.
And then,
uh,
quite often I'll audibly go right.
And it wasn't planned,
right?
It just,
it just went and it was sort of a half laugh that you do when you're by yourself
and you say,
think of something funny,
but you don't want to do a full laugh,
you know?
So there's sort of thing,
there are other times when,
um,
so for example,
I told you the story about being in the shower and thinking as the entire plot
for God's debris in one moment.
You know,
my entire body lit up.
Um,
when I had the idea for the blog that I wrote recently,
they're just sort of lit up the Internet.
Um,
I felt it as a full body experience long before I wrote it.
Right?
And so that's,
that's largely true.
Now with Dilbert,
if you do this long enough,
a lot of the things that used to be technique just get baked into your
personality after awhile.
And so there's stuff you do as second nature that you've got to moving art into
the domain of craft.
Right?
So for example,
I know,
cause I've learned over time that there are six elements of dimension of humor,
six dimensions of humor.
And if I use at least two of them,
I've got a joke.
If I use three of them,
school probably going to be a really good joke.
But that's not enough.
There's still that,
um,
there's something about it that x factor,
that thing you can't put your foot,
your finger on,
that just makes your body move.
You know,
it just moves your body.
And if he can't get that,
um,
no craft in the world can survive,
you know,
he can't resuscitate it.
And have you,
have you,
have you written about the six elements of humor before?
I did.
I,
I've written about it a number of times.
I think if anybody googles,
my name's Scott Adams and six dimensions of humor,
you'll see.
Yeah,
you'll see a few references to it.
Got It.
And,
um,
what,
what would be two examples of the six?
Just just for fun.
Oh,
I know you're good at this because you know what you just did that was just so
smart.
If you had,
if you had asked me for the six,
I would have changed the subject because I know,
but you asked me for two cause you know,
I could come up with to,
uh,
all right,
so I would go for sex because you've now made it,
you've made it safe for me to do that.
I'm wonderful.
Um,
so there's cute,
there's bizarre,
there's recognizable,
there's naughty.
Uh,
how many was that?
Yeah,
you're already way ahead of the game.
You've got four,
you got cute,
bizarre,
recognizable and naughty that you don't have to Google the rest a little bit.
Let me give you an example.
Um,
so cute is usually a kids and dogs,
right?
So,
and bizarre is just anything that's not in a place.
So if you know you're a cartoon history,
you will know that a,
the far side use primarily the dimension of putting something out of place.
So you'd have an animal talking.
So as soon as the animals talking,
he's got one dimension.
All right.
So he is basically starting a race and he's already ahead of you.
If you're the cartoonists do sitting there saying,
I think I'll do a comic about anything.
I the world is my canvas.
Right?
But he started,
he started ahead of you already.
So he's got the bizarre and then he'll have the animal say something often in
the framing or the type of mood that a human would say.
Right?
So that's recognizable part.
So if you could put yourself in the picture and say,
Aha,
Oh God,
I recognize that situation.
Uh,
but it's an animal talking.
Um,
clearly there's more to it than that.
Again,
that's just the,
you have to have at least that two dimensions.
Um,
take a look at the best comic strip of all time that I think nearly everyone in
the world would say.
Um,
Calvin and Hobbes,
there's a,
there's a talking tiger that is both bizarre and cute.
All right?
So he took,
um,
the far side one dimension further as a starting point.
All right.
The,
the moment you start reading Calvin and Hobbs,
you already have cute cause his drawing is amazing.
Both of the child and the,
you know,
he's got a double cute is going a child and an animal and it's a cool animal.
Right?
So he starts that before even writes a joke so that if he has the kid doing
something,
you know,
nobody or um,
um,
also anything bad happening to anybody is of course,
uh,
one of the dimensions.
So cruelty did,
I mentioned cruelty,
they might have to five yet
you're up to five.
That's number five.
By the end of this interview,
I will have come up with that six one and I'm going to,
I'm going to scream it in the middle of whatever other unrelated question.
Or You could just leave people with bated breath to,
to tap Google into their keyboards.
That's,
that's another,
another way to get them to go to your site,
I'm sure.
Uh,
but uh,
we've,
we've got cruelty.
What it,
what are some of the most,
um,
or could you be just one underrated or underappreciated cartoonists in your
mind?
People that perhaps listeners haven't checked out that they should check out?
I would say a comic calledF minus f being,
you know,
like you're a failure f I,
you can Google that.
It's,
it's syndicated and uh,
that's the one that makes me laugh.
The most of the ones you haven't heard of,
cool.
Of the ones you may have heard of that also makes me laugh the most,
um,
pearls before swine.
Um,
and that would be no accident because he literally studied the,
you know,
the two of six rule.
And um,
you know,
I,
I had conversations with him when he was coming up and you can see that he's one
of the few cartoonists whose approach to it the way I have,
which is as a business,
not just an art.
Right.
And so he's used the most methodical operator out there now in terms of doing
what is the smartest thing to do for your art.
Cool.
F minus and pearls before swine.
I will check out both of those,
actually have not checked out either.
Uh,
I want to be respectful of your time,
but I would love to ask a couple of rapid fire questions.
The answers don't have to be rapid,
but I'd love to just ask a couple of short questions,
uh,
before we come up on time,
if that's okay with you.
Sure.
And I know you want to ask me about the voice thing.
Ah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well we could do that first.
I mean,
could you describe what happened to you and what you learned from that
experience?
I mean,
and there's,
there's a fair amount out there for people to want to dig into the specifics of
the condition and so on.
But maybe you could just give people an overview of what happened because it's
terrifying,
right?
So I'm not going to give like a big scary medical thing.
I new show.
It'd be terrible and people can Google it.
If you googled,
uh,
spasmodic Dysphonia,
you would learn that I,
and tens of thousands of other people at this problem where you lose your voice.
Um,
meaning that a clips,
uh,
your,
your vocal cords spazz at times when you don't want them to.
So he can't get out,
um,
words that makes sense.
Uh,
it was so unknown that it took me a long time to figure out what it was.
And I had to figure out using Google and hunting down a doctor and doctor to
doctor and you know,
my path went through,
you know,
Japan down to USC.
And finally Dr. Gerald Burke,
who had invented a surgery that was not well publicized that a worked for me.
So I've been,
since I've been active trying to tell people who have spasmodic Dysphonia,
which by the way,
I'm going to do an audio impression of it because there are people listening to
this guaranteed who have it and don't know they have it because they had never
heard anyone else who spoke that way.
And they're trying to figure out what it is.
So I'm going to do an impression and I'm going to send a,
like three dozen people to their doctor with a solution.
All right,
here's my impression.
If I were to order a diet coke,
um,
since my vocal chords would clench,
especially on some problems,
syllables,
um,
it would come out like a clipped,
cell phone.
So instead of a diet coke and we're,
we're,
can I have a diet coke?
It would come out as an I guy coat like that.
So it sounds like you're just dropping syllables.
So everybody at home who said,
Holy Shit,
I know somebody like that.
Um,
the,
the name for it is spasmodic Dysphonia,
but I got something much cooler.
You want to hear it?
I do.
That's on this.
We might be able to solve this problem today.
This is literally,
this is literally true.
I might actually be able to,
with your help,
solve the entire problem for 50,000 people in this country.
Maybe it's a long shot,
right?
Let's give it a go,
but I'm going to take it all right.
The surgery fixed me and what that involved was cutting some nerves in my neck
that disconnected my brain from my vocal cords for three and a half months.
They spliced in a new network that takes three and a half months to regrow.
And once it regrows that I could talk,
but very weakly.
And it took her years to get my voice back to where it is.
What's interesting about that is nobody knows why that works.
Because the problem has been well identified to be a little left brain hiccup.
So you don't,
you don't fix your brain by rewiring the nerves in your neck.
Now hold that thought.
Nobody knows why the surgery works.
Now the only other thing that works for this that I've personally verified,
cause I've talked to the individuals who've done this and I actually went
through this training myself,
was a doctor who some thought was a,
was a not because science was not quite supporting his method,
but you would go in and he would say everybody hum at the key of f for weeks and
tried to never talk at your natural deeper tone instead of just Tom.
Now I think it might've worked for 10 or 20% of the people.
But keep in mind this is an incurable problem,
right?
At 10 to 20% of the people walked out with perfect voices.
I spoke to,
uh,
one of them,
actually several of them I spoke to live,
so I verified and one of them crossed over my week.
So I know it's a real person,
not a shell or something.
Now what do these two things,
the surgery,
which nobody knows why it works and the humming in the key of F,
which nobody knows why it works.
What did they have in common in both of those cases?
It's the only time the subject takes an extended period without reinjuring the
muscles and the vocal courts.
Hmm.
Uh,
so there is a non zero chance and I actually act,
um,
saw my surgeon,
like a couple of months ago just had a,
an event and I said,
is it possible that the only reason that your surgery works is that you
prevented me from reinjuring the muscles of my vocal cords for long enough for
them to heal for the first time ever.
Because when you have this problem,
you ended up straining it every single day cause you're trying really hard to
talk.
It's just not working.
So imagine if you had a sprained ankle and you ran a marathon every day.
I would never heal.
Right.
So the humming in the key of f uses different equipment like it uses just a,
you know,
or,
or maybe it just has less of a pressure on the same equipment.
I don't know.
And by the way,
I'm talking at what I can best approximate as the key of f I have.
I'm tone deaf so I'm not sure I'm getting there.
Um,
my normal speaking voice is actually much lower and I do that to preserve my,
my speaking mechanism.
That's one of the things you learn.
So put those two things together.
The only two things,
these two things that are the only things that work to,
to solve the spasmodic Dysphonia is people didn't talk not even a little bit
using their normal voice for an extended period.
Um,
three and a half months in one case,
maybe as few as a week or two weeks in the other case.
But if you have this or you know somebody who does and you're listening to this,
somebody out there,
I want you to see if you're in a special situation where this makes sense for
you.
Just don't talk for two weeks.
If you've got maybe a spouse who can answer the phone or type of job where you
can do an email just as an experiment.
And then the email,
he as at a,
you'll see my email address or you can find me on Twitter or anything.
Ah,
you see bay addresses in the Strip every day.
And tell me if it worked.
Cause if I could get three people in the world that this works for Tim,
we just fixed the problem.
It can be a really big break.
So,
you know,
I love this idea and for those people who might be considering this,
uh,
who think they might be a candidate or you could also look at,
for instance,
uh,
silent meditation retreats.
There are 10 to 14 days,
silent meditation retreats through groups like Spirit Rock and others.
So you could actually create a context,
uh,
wherein that is reinforced,
right?
Not only it's,
it's not just willpower,
but you're in an environment where it's not permitted.
So that,
that could be also something to look into.
But no,
this is very exciting.
I liked,
uh,
I should say that whispering is still a perfectly allowed because that doesn't
use your vocal chords so you can communicate with anybody you want to in a quiet
room during this quiet period.
This is very interesting.
Well,
I'm glad we touched on that.
And again,
I have to emphasize,
it's totally a long shot,
but there's somebody who listened to this was going to try it and we'll find
out.
But the long shots are worth it.
I mean you mentioned 10 to 20% with the humming in the key of f.
If that were a drug for a,
for a major condition and the people for whom it didn't work had an a side
effects that would,
that would stand a good chance of getting commercialized.
So I mean that's,
that's a viable,
so a viable tool if you have a one in five chance of being awesome.
Well listen to this,
the um,
it gets more interesting because this is more validation for why this might
work.
This doctor could get no credibility because when he would report is cures,
which he was shouting at the top is his voice.
He was making videos,
showing the people,
showing them the actual people talking before it,
after it was as convincing as it possibly could be.
And when he would take it to the medical community,
they would say,
oh,
it looks like all that happened here is that you,
these people were misdiagnosed in the first place,
so you didn't cure spasmodic dysphonia.
These are people who just had strained voice boxes or strain,
whatever vocal chords and you let them rest and for a while and now they're
better.
I say,
maybe that's everybody.
Right,
right.
For sure.
Definitely.
I mean that's a,
it's kind of not entirely a perfect parallel,
but a lot of people who consider themselves hard gainers,
meaning they,
they have difficulty gaining muscle mass is particularly true with men are
simply training.
Too often they,
they,
they are not physiologically capable of recovering from the,
the stress that they're imposing on themselves.
They never,
uh,
they never,
sort of super compensate and experience this,
this hypertrophy.
So it's just a matter of removing stimuli as opposed to adding something,
you know,
the subtraction versus versus addition with just very
anti Western medicine.
And a lot of respects,
but,
um,
in,
in the conventional sense,
let me,
let me ask you,
let me ask you this.
What,
what,
besides your own books,
what book or books have you given most as a gift?
I've never given a book as a gift.
You haven't?
Wow.
Okay.
No,
this is interesting.
So what do you give gifts?
Maybe that sounds like a weird question,
but I mean,
if you do,
I'd be curious to know what you,
you often give as gifts.
Um,
I retired from the gift giving business a while ago.
which takes a long time to train everybody,
but
no,
I,
I replaced that in favor of being a,
you know,
a nice person on the general basis.
Right.
You know,
like maybe I want to buy you something today.
it doesn't need to be reasonable.
So no,
I don't,
I don't do gifts in particular,
but I'd say if you're looking for a book that I think everybody should read,
perfect.
It would be a book called influence,
um,
by,
uh,
I don't know how to pronounce it.
She Aldine or Cialdini.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the part I was choking on it.
I didn't know how to pronounce the first part,
but it's C,
I a l,
D,
I n I 100% of effect of people seem to have read.
Read that book.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's one of those things that would I beat somebody in,
they're operating at a pretty high level.
If you mentioned that book,
they've all read it.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's very consistent.
But if you talk to the general public,
it's still that well known.
Then I would add to that,
uh,
I haven't read these books,
but I took the Dale Carnegie course and if the books say anything that is as
useful as the course,
that's probably a good thing.
I hear good things about him.
I'm a big fan of a lot of his work in particular,
not the how to win friends and influence people,
but how to stop worrying and start living,
which I think is it fantastically well written book on anxiety and there's a
law,
there's a bit of material on the physiology and so on.
That's this outdated,
but the vast majority is,
is fantastically well done.
Well that that needs it update because I have a theory that there's a real,
um,
there's something like called the digital disease,
meaning that if you take the average person and put them in the average simple
environment of the past,
they were not overwhelmed by its complexity.
But I believe that today the average person is overwhelmed by the complexity of
life because it got more complicated and that,
um,
I barely know an adult who is not some kind of drug either prescribed or
otherwise to deal with anxiety.
And I'm pretty sure that wasn't the case when I was a kid.
Maybe we have more options now I guess.
I think there's like a real legitimate mental illness.
Plague.
I agree.
I totally agree.
And I think,
and I think I saw you mentioned something along these lines on Twitter,
but it's,
we're in an a distraction economy,
right?
I mean,
we,
it's not only limited to a box in our living room,
but we have,
we have obviously the,
the phones,
the tablets,
the laptops.
Now we have wearables.
Uh,
let me,
let me emphasize that point because I realized I sounded like a old lady.
Get off my lawn.
Um,
uh,
stop this,
stop this new technology stuff.
But I think most people who move here to me now that I'm very pro future and
technology,
so yeah,
not saying we should,
we should back up but keep in mind the names of these biggest companies in your,
your world like Google,
apple,
they're their business model is distraction.
You know,
your smartphone,
all of that depends on them taking you off your task and making you look at an
advertisement or by their new songs or by their new thing going to look at a new
app or something.
So they're literally in the business of making you distracted and doing the job
that the smartest people in the world using the best science and ab testing can
provide while in the normal world you had,
it was a fair fight,
right?
You're like,
Hey,
I'm going to ignore your billboard on the highway cause I can,
it wasn't that hard.
Haha.
Those guys with the billboards,
they were using a ton of science.
But now,
now it's me against all the sciences and Google.
All right.
It's,
it's total.
It's a total stack deck.
Not In your favor.
Yeah.
Uh,
before you call this true story.
So as part of your process,
I'm,
your assistant sent me a form that needed to be filled out in order to do the
process of finding it in my email,
printing it out.
Or in this case,
realizing that I had to print out something to look at to realize I didn't need
to print something out.
It's,
you know,
it's only two minutes.
Right,
right.
Totally worth the time.
Not Complaining about the process.
A a completely necessary,
but in that two minutes I only had one hope to be able to complete that to me,
a task within the hour so that I'd have it in on time for the,
for this.
And the only hope was chanting it continually to keep the other thoughts out of
my head.
So,
so for five minutes,
I simply chanted,
print the form,
print the form.
I would pick,
I would pick up my phone just by reflex and start to hit Twitter while I'm
chanting.
And I was like,
no,
I actually have to yell at myself.
I yell at my head,
no,
no.
I yell at us all the way back at the tape and then I go print the form,
print the form.
And after I printed it,
I still had to w that I learned I really needed to do something online instead.
And so I had to find that again.
So now like find the email,
find the email.
So without that I don't have a hope and I need to do that more often I think.
Yeah.
Psych holding up a shield to deflect all of the incoming distraction.
And you mentioned billboards.
If you could have one billboard anywhere with anything on it,
what would it say and where do you put it?
Ah,
it would say be useful.
It would be everywhere.
So I realized one day that I could boil down my entire philosophy of how to live
into those two words.
Just be useful.
That's useful.
Yeah.
That,
that comes from my farming,
upgrading.
My white mother grew up in a farm and I grew up next to the farm she grew up on.
So I worked on it with like grandparents and stuff.
Um,
and they're,
you know,
there's no wasted energy,
right.
Cause can afford it.
Yeah.
Wait,
waste is death.
So you,
you know,
you didn't leave,
you always pitched in,
you didn't,
you didn't wait for somebody to ask.
You just be useful.
And so I,
you know,
having now made the money that I need to bake,
I'm far more focused on the being useful to the rest of the world,
part of the equation for the second half of my life and far more enjoyable.
So if,
you know,
if somebody says,
how do I be happy,
how do I be happy?
You know,
the biggest question in the world,
I'd say be useful.
It works every time.
It doesn't sometimes work.
Be useful because what,
guess what?
People like it,
they want to be with you.
You're useful.
Yeah.
People want to hire you.
You're useful.
Everything comes together.
If you just do that one thing and that dovetails back to,
you know,
the product is you,
that the project is,
is semi relevant.
Whether it succeeds,
what really matters is did you become a more valuable and therefore more useful
person at the end of it?
Definitely.
And you mentioned,
you mentioned happy.
I think a lot of people strive to be happy.
A lot of people also strive to be successful and that means different things to
different people.
When you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind for you?
Well,
Donald Trump,
but only because he's in the news.
It was,
you know,
so,
so I think the test was completely polluted when I think is successful.
I would say,
um,
if I think of it for two seconds,
Bill Gates and,
uh,
there's nobody in second place.
Why is that?
First of all,
he amassed a huge amount of money,
but it do,
it did so in a way that made the world forever better.
Right.
And,
and I'm sure that,
you know,
now that you see how the second half of his life is going,
I think that he always needed something that didn't just make money.
You know,
I think the putting the computer on every,
not every desk or whatever,
uh,
was a real thing.
Um,
I believe he invests that money largely so he could do the second part of his
life.
And now you take the smartest,
most rational human,
um,
the world has ever produced a and find out,
we'll surprise everything you thought about him wasn't exactly what you thought.
And years ago when he said his plan was to give it away and nobody really took
that seriously.
Guess what?
He's doing that too.
And the way he's doing it is,
is picking the thing that governments can't do and poor people can't do.
He's pay east taking not only the place that has the greatest leverage cause you
know,
you can go in with his brains and money and in scientific ways and you know,
the,
the energy that he attracted himself and pick off these things.
You know,
his contribution to Africa by the time he,
you know,
takes the dirt nap or transfers is a life force.
It's a software which I think is far more likely in this case.
They may rename the nation after him home.
You know,
it might,
it might be the continent of Bill Gates when he's done.
And I'm not sure if everybody sees this company.
I mean he's working on stuff like fixing water,
you know,
like how,
how would everybody liked to have water?
Would that be good?
I mean he's going after the biggest targets with some guns that have all the
ammunition that you need to go after those targets and nobody else can do it.
He's a very impressive guy.
I heard a,
a first person anecdote from a friend of mine who,
uh,
somehow ended up going on a bird watching tour with Bill Gates.
It's a small group of people end up and Bill Gates spent maybe an hour of the
night before reading a birdwatching guide.
And according to my friend,
I mean literally had perfect factual recall of that book on the tour the next
day to the point where he could talk to this professional bird guide in a
tropical environment on a peer level.
A just mind boggling.
I mean talk about CPU power.
Um,
uh,
what advice and I'll just ask you one or two more questions.
What advice would you give to your 30 year old self,
30 year old self?
Um,
that was a,
that was a time of great transition.
I would say probably patients because you know,
I've been playing the system game and not the goal game since,
um,
since I got into college and literally have a diary in which I,
I wrote my master plan.
If you take,
you know,
10 years following up a process and it's not giving you a results that's hard to
remain patient.
So in retrospect,
that was the only thing I needed to,
uh,
to maybe alleviate some of my pain.
But on the other hand,
inpatients probably drove me harder.
So maybe I wouldn't tell myself that either.
And if,
if you're a 30 year old self said,
how,
how exactly do you propose IB patient,
what would you,
how would you respond to that?
Um,
well my 30 year old self wouldn't have access to medical marijuana,
so I would have to have a limited
limited canvass with which to paint.
Um,
I,
I've always made it a,
a,
a top priority since I was a teenager and had tons of stress related medical
problems to make that job.
One,
to learn how to have stress.
I would consider myself a world champion at avoiding stress at this point in
dozens of different ways.
And a lot of it is just how you look at the world,
but most of it is,
um,
is really the process of a diversification.
So I'm not going to worry about losing one friend if I have a hundred,
but if I have two friends,
I'm really going to be worried,
not,
not going to worry about losing my job because my one boss is going to fire me.
Um,
because I have thousands of Boston said newspapers everywhere and lots of them
could like me one day.
And it doesn't make any difference to my life.
So what are the ways to not worry about stresses,
to eliminate it?
I don't worry about my,
my stock picks because I have a diversified portfolio.
So diversification,
it works in almost every area of your life to reduce your stress.
I love this.
Well Scott,
we need to hang out more.
We need to play more tennis.
We should get in Deval in the room to just up the intensity quotient to also,
not that we need it,
but uh,
it always fun to,
uh,
to,
to chat with you and uh,
where can people learn more about you,
find you online,
say hello,
where would you like people to,
to check you out?
Um,
I would like people to go to [inaudible] dot com and check out my blog if they
like my non humor thoughts.
Um,
pretty soon,
uh,
my startup,
which is now called a calendar tree.com we'll have little pivot and have a new
name,
um,
and we'll make lots of noise about that,
but you will,
will you want to watch for that?
And,
uh,
what is your,
what is your Twitter handle?
If people want to pin you on Twitter,
uh,
Scott Adams says,
and if you could make just in closing one ask or a recommendation to the people
listening to this,
what would,
what would that be?
Besides checking your stuff out,
think of your life as a system.
Think of yourself as the most important part of the system.
Be Useful and make yourself more valuable as you go.
I love it.
It's everybody listening for,
for links.
I'll also include specific links to a couple of popular posts on Scott's
blogged.
Just visit the show notes.
Everything we mentioned will be in there.
Four hour workweek.com forward slash podcast all spelled out and uh,
Scott,
keep creating man.
I love your stuff and uh,
hope to see you again soon.
Thank you Tim.
I love this.
Let's do it again.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.
Your one stop shop for all things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch
of my startups already use Vimeo pro including wealth front who uses it to
explain how wealth front works task grab,
it,
uses it to tell their company story and there are many other names that you'd
recognize among their customers,
airbnb,
Etsy,
et cetera.
Why do they use it?
Well then you approached provides enterprise level video hosting for a fraction
of the usual cost.
Features include gorgeous high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and they fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro,
et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated bandwidth calculations or hidden fees and
you can try it risk free for 30 days,
so check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business.
That's the I n e o.com forward slash business and use Promo Code Tim to get 25%
off.
That's a special discount just for you guys.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business promo code.
Tim,
and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Yeah.